two
oh hello welcome everybody it's Gwen
today and uh we're here second day back
yes
good to be back
um
not a lot of enthusiasm there was like a
golf club back there
hmm
there it is
I'm not gonna read that out loud
just as long as it's entertaining
oh
I'm not gonna read it I'm not gonna read
it
[Music]
yeah I got it
oh that's swaggy how's that is that how
they do that six five four three two
twenty-one
[Music]
wow wow
Bravo I can't tell if that's um
Colleen or Olivia
who's staying all aboard that was
Colleen oh I swear to God play The Sound
by I I no offense I just can't tell the
difference
Jesus 90 million more times
yes I'm the only one huh I don't know
maybe it's because I listen to her speak
for so so many years
well anyway we have a great show here
which is uh unusual the reason we have a
good show is because there's just so
much stuff to talk about from our break
we barely scratched the surface of it
all
today love is going to be eating the
spicy chip
how we feeling about that love I'm
feeling good Bob I know it's going to be
horrible it's a rite of passage I think
we've all done it at this point yeah no
I'm
ready to face the consequences there it
is you'll be fine you'll be fine you're
doing prep right you're eating I've been
eating there's some meat some salad good
I've been hitting that Pepto good okay
good good good you've been doing all the
right things oh yeah
have you had Taco Bell today no but I
was contemplating getting it today too
smart yeah and what are we gonna order
you missed the days when when talk about
how that little dog that had like a
Mexican accent oh
let's see I kind of need him back that
[__] was wild wasn't it rest in peace
rip to the goat you think you think
people get mad if they did that today
I mean it was just no people love
talking dogs
[Music]
okay I want to god let's not do that
that's
I'm gonna make that dog look like a
saint by comparison yeah civil rights
civil rights fighter
yeah
okay so we got that coming up I have
more Colleen updates
um
Cav update oh Mama I've been waiting to
talk about this one all about the Cav
cap train fousey updates
um oh yeah and this is one I've been
wanting to talk about the Jonah Hill
leaked texts
we've all been waiting to hear about
Jonah Hill
yeah here's the uh new character that
nobody ever
that's not true Jonah Hill is very
topical
right well now because of this here's
our boy
[Music]
yes he said it
it still hits still hits
he's back baby let's get that he's back
and he's ready to [__]
[Music]
right that's the sexy girl uh Chihuahua
there
give me that Taco Bell Taco Bell I want
some of that Taco Bell
that's you love
Chihuahua or whatever that thing is
you're right
[Music]
do you like like authentic Mexican food
love are you just into the Taco Bell oh
authentic like Taco Bell no not Taco
Bell like some Mexican
um family or no no no I do in a taco
truck you know I [__] with those white
tents on the sidewalk is that authentic
oh yeah
yeah and I like that too because you get
to put on the vegetables and I put
nothing on yeah yeah that's the real
[__] yeah there you go so cool those the
ones that stay open super late when you
go with all your friends after us wait
you hit up the white tents yeah you hit
up the white tines after you go yeah no
I know about that but I'm surprised
Love's been out I did it last year I
haven't done it this year but I love you
get to put some salsa on there they dip
the onion skip the cilantro optional
veggies love that yeah it's nice it's
nice yeah if in Taco Bell or
I just referred to Mexico as Taco Bell
in Mexico
my parents lived there I know I
mentioned that but I'm just saying it
they lived there for a while the white
tents are they they're there really yeah
that's that's the authentic Mexican
experience that's how they sell and they
also selling tacos at 3am they got the
white 10 out God damn
what that's how you know
what's your problem with that uh
Roseanne
just pointing out that they're white
tens that's all she said why oh no she
said white oh white they're white [__]
was why I love her
Yeah tomorrow's our new Teddy fresh
collection
if anyone's interested we got swimwear
coming out
this is actually swimwear the shirt and
pants here for the men
unisex
I mean this one's unisex too if you
think you could slip into it
I would struggle
there's not a lot of space for the male
genitals
but uh squeeze them in there
why you make that face I just
misunderstood what you were oh okay I
thought you were saying you were well
endowed Dan that's I don't think you
have to be well in down not to squeeze
into those
but anyway
it's exciting that and a lot of other
stuff which I'm waiting to get uh some
pictures of
so okay let's oh Philly D Billy Billy D
came out got my face in a thumbnail
friend of the show
he got a new haircut by the way he's
looking cool what do you guys think oh
yeah I think it's a good look I noticed
it
I think yeah he looked I mean he slimmed
down the hair slimmed down the body
slimmed down oh I'm not sorry I'm not
supposed to talk like he looks good he
looks good sorry no he looks good that's
all sorry sorry that's a fact
all right
[Laughter]
did he use a fat pic of me though is
that fat Ethan
because people if people start you doing
that then I'm gonna have to be calling
out Fab phobia
because I know you don't want any photos
I don't I know you don't want me to
discuss it Phil but I'm gonna have to
say
I don't mind discussing my body and I'm
calling you out right now fat phobia
you know what the Philly stands for
fat phobia oh boy different letters
Philly was so nice in his videos he was
thank you
major King with an incredible new
haircut Taco Bell we're waiting
where are you Taco Bell I'll hire the
I'll hire the Taco Bell dog
unfortunately the Taco Bell dog is no
longer how do you know that I got that I
remember when they announced that the
dog died and I was very sad oh no yeah
how did he pass
Ed old age happy on top of a pile of
tacos just like he wanted well if he was
eating that taco meat yeah no then
that's gonna he actually died at three
years old
away
yeah Gidget
uh died on Gidget they should have
changed that did you die on July 21st
2009 July 21st is my birthday dude what
a horrible birthday present how old was
he I blocked that out is he about at age
of 15 actually after suffering a stroke
what an idiot dumbass no [__] has a
stroke Punk
oh thank you Sam I got a promo of the
collection coming out tomorrow and I I
can't wear any of it because it's all
got green
this is a shirt I'm wearing
this is all tomorrow at 10 A.M eat your
heart out
this shirt is awesome that's one we were
wearing yesterday this one I was wearing
yesterday it's very fun
the pants okay
we got giblets
I don't know you called those
giblets what do you call the things you
put on crops I don't know so I I don't
want to I don't wanna
like chicken food or something
uh giblets is like it's like the the
guts that you don't normally eat right
right that you get to the dog right
this is a hit uh the the sweater still
be with us
uh a dress loving that all happening
tomorrow at
teddyfresh.com 10 A.M PST we're moving
along we're loving it oh that's
everything so there it is check it out
thank you
so let's see what Philly had to say
about me because I always kind of like
to rate his review of things and then
decide if I like him this week or not
roll it
so here's Philly D
ude roll it
today we're talking about the
jaw-dropping update to the Colleen
Ballinger toxic gossip train situation
wait what what he's shot what he's
showing doesn't match up
it's because you'll see poor kid's
pursuit of just getting a new friend
Senator tuberville's unhinged interview
where he defended white nationalists
Microsoft and Sweden scored massive wins
today we're going to talk about all that
and so much more on today's brand new
Philip DeFranco show you daily dive into
the news so buckle up hit that like
button and let's just jump into it oh
yeah well so we decide he tells me to
hit the like button
and I'm a somewhat of a contrarian
what makes you want to download so but
but let's see how his coverage is and if
it's good then I'm gonna like the video
smash that like button
manager situation just took a surprising
turn that's not to say that a number of
people predicted it or at the very why
is he still showing Activision Blizzard
headlines
that's a good question that's suspicions
it could go this way because it now
what's happening Phil gossip train is
copyrighted several channels now
claiming for Ballinger copyright claimed
this is
something yeah
okay Phil we have a problem
his part's out of sync oh I think it
there's a bug happening something
removed
oh today we're talking about the what
what did he cut something and it got uh
because that's happened to us before the
audio gets out of this song
oh yeah
no Philly no Billy I'm sorry we caught
you slipping
God
all right well let's hear what you had
to say I guess responding to the
allegations and scanned and among those
seemingly affected you had the H3
podcast with them having been on break
for the last two weeks and then their
comeback show yesterday the agency is
currently suing Microsoft and Activision
to block a massive six to nine billion
acquisitions
uh-huh right I'm just um
video as well as a subsequent public
reaction Nathan Klein later sharing on
Twitter that Ballinger was copyright
claiming them for featuring the song in
their video but also in addition to them
you had places like spillty a gossip
page also being dinged for featuring the
song and their discussion as well it
doesn't really matter what he's saying
it kind of [__] me right well are you
paying more attention to the visual or
the audio now I'm just looking at his
face and I feel like it Matt it works
like it doesn't really matter
you know it looks like she uploaded it
it's almost like gameplay footage right
yeah yeah it's uh uh Counter-Strike yeah
surfing just throw it up there you're
good hang on Apple music which isn't the
best look and so these updates to the
situation have prompted a new Fresh wave
of backlash but people saying that it
appears to confirm the belief that she
maybe went the weird route of making the
reaction a song so that she could listen
with the Jaws kid
oh no did she groom no I know everything
about this kid I know everything is a
weenie no guys this poor kid it was it's
footage from someone's ring camera of
him ringing the doorbell and being like
do you have any kids do you have any
kids
um like I don't have any friends and
then they're like I think that there are
kids next door and the kid and the kid
is like no those kids bully me and it's
just a super and then he was like
offered money and people were like no he
just wants friends guys Colleen's door
by chance I hope um he sounds like a
troubled youth and that's exactly
Colleen do you have friends do you can I
be your friend come in Child of course
come in this tampon in your mouth come
in oh
I mean that's historically accurate
let's be honest for a second I love him
though I hope he found friends no me too
he got a lot of love from the internet
that's good that's just what he meant
cool shirt too I mean
I want to give that kid some Roblox dude
he doesn't need friends Roblox yeah Fair
all the friends you ever need are
waiting for you iPad and that's it
seriously
reacting to with one he was also arguing
it's funny to me that she accuses Adam
of trying to monetize this whole thing
when she monetized her apology video and
is now copyrighted oh I didn't know
about that wrinkle she accused Adam of
monetizing the gossip that's what Philly
said
he went the weird route of me that was
the substance of the song was it not
like doing it for cloud yeah and okay
monetize your lies come on don't you
know the song yeah yeah to celebrate my
device
right okay fair that's a joke that's a
good part that's a good point a song so
that she could later copyright strike
anyone that was reacting to with one he
was also arguing it's funny to me that
she accuses Adam of trying to monetize
this whole thing when she monetized her
apology video and is now copyright
claiming people to add [__] gotta recoup
that cancel tour money somehow that
being in reference to Ballinger's live
shows for the remainder of the year now
reportedly being canceled stop playing
the the Jaws kid like this Billy what's
one got to do with the other
you know like the kids just looking for
friends why you got to be talking about
calling grooming people yeah with him at
the doorbell it's not right
don't do it I'll give him the look
[Applause]
Phil your shit's [__] up though
shit's [__]
um this is me right now this is so me
right now
that's right
oh yeah you know what's the difference
between me and him
I don't [__] my sister
that's right uh big difference and you
didn't kill your dad big difference yeah
yeah so Colleen yesterday I think before
I think we were the first ones and this
really
there was this
what it was in my opinion a laughable
theory that or a joke really that she
waited for us to go on vacation to drop
her ukulele vid
and people are saying hmm that might
actually be true because this happened
was it the next day or the evening of it
was the evening of I think like three
hours after today we're talking
CD Baby
which I uh CD Baby is just like
one of those publishing platforms right
you just upload music and you can
publish it on iTunes and all that yeah
the name is pretty funny though you
gotta admit that
so go back to the Philly video there's
actually a there's an update in the
pinned comment
talking about why the audio's out of
sync and it actually has uh some today
information about the whole situation
too let's see okay okay okay update we
tried to update the video causing
temporary processing syncing issues
we've been there are reaching out to get
YouTube to get it fixed you know what he
has to do to get fixed it's so [__] up
he has to
um actually he's not that [__] up he
sends them the full video this is what
we had to do maybe it was [__] up
because ours were like three hours long
yes you have to send them the full video
and then they do a full-on swap you have
to wait for them
to do that
he says I think it should be fixed
relatively soon this was two hours ago
Phil
Define relative
yeah
additional update we're going to talk
about in today's show Colleen
Ballinger's team reached out regarding
the iTunes and the copyright allegation
said Mrs Ballinger did not upload the
video song to me Apple music or to any
other streaming platforms for sale or
for any other purpose Ms Bellinger has
not monetized the video song in any way
we don't know how it got published on
those platforms it was done without Miss
Ballinger's knowledge or authorization
and we have taken measures to have the
content removed likewise Miss Ballinger
has not issued any copyright
infringement claims to channels
featuring the song so here okay
[Music]
hey guess what that song's about to go
on iTunes published by Colleen Ballinger
uh I don't necessarily think it's a lie
no I don't I don't either we thought
that that was a possibility that
somebody was trolling but I am curious
now I don't think that she put it up
I'll I'll meet her there but it is
curious because when before we do shows
we upload Clips to see if they get
copyright claimed now you guys uploaded
two test Clips right both of them had
the copyright
yeah
released correct okay
now the podcast which was the first
recipient of this as far as I can tell
uh is still yeah it's still claiming
it's still claimed
and it says very clearly here
if you here let me pull up the the
screenshots
uh
where are these it says uh CD Baby Co on
behalf of Colleen Bellinger
but yeah I guess somebody could have
just set up an account on Ce baby with
her name but
that seems insane
like why is that so easy to do that's
crazy that's pretty baffling uh to me as
well and then you don't have to it's
just like cool right it happened with uh
I believe Shane Dawson a little bit ago
uh someone wrote a song like I [__] my
cat or something like that oh and then
they said it was published by Shane
right
memory serves me that's what happened
okay but like YouTube's like cool
go ahead and claim this uh Five Hour
podcast with like two million views it's
all yours
it's all yours baby
so I just wonder if if it is indeed
Colleen is taking care of this
then why is it that they've all been
dropped but hours is it possible that we
[__] ourselves by disputing it
no the dispute doesn't doesn't if you
can drop it at any time okay got it yeah
I think I my my theory potentially is
that she's like Drop it not you
[__] that dude it's possible well it in
that statement would indicate she's got
nothing to do with it but I guess it
wouldn't be
[Music]
I don't know who knows well why is it
that ours is the only one that didn't
get dropped I don't know you know
uh I love this comment though there's
people writing for her in the comments
apparently to be fair it's not
royalty-free music and you played the
whole song what did you expect right
you're right parking Tigers you're
absolutely right glad you have a blue
check mark too dumbass paying for
Twitter you [__]
[__] Punk well I uh I messaged pop
crave
I didn't message pop crave I quote
tweeted them so can you please tell her
legal reps that she still has our
podcast claimed XOXO hugs and kisses
yeah
professional perfect so I don't know
should I write YouTube and tell them
that it's like
fraudulent
uh if you think that would help sure
I guess I'll do that after the show
I think there's a chance they just were
like not you
you know I'm not sure
dropped it I mean her lawyers could be
lying too let's be honest
let's go I think it's illegal for
lawyers to lie right Dan yeah her
lawyers could be lying
why does it lie we should try putting a
song on CD Baby and see I want to see
how easy is this
you can you can do it with one of my
songs so we're not doing anything
illegal okay
uh we're not going to claim anybody
but just grab
one of my songs [__] [__] matzo or
whatever oh I can't oh I shouldn't say
that word anymore I gotta change the
title of that song yeah
that's horrible
little person matzah
doesn't have the same ring I'll have to
revise that
I have a song that I was called [__]
matzah that's uh everybody loves but
that's an offensive word
tiny matzah
small small Mata
the problem is it's in the song like I
say [__] you're sorry apologies
probably like 50 times
that's unfortunate your meter is
climbing right now
they said it
that's gonna be a problem why did no one
ever mention that by the way everyone
nobody even mentioned that that you know
what I mean I I'd be honored to rewrite
it with you
you want to go down that task yeah
Taylor Swift's re-releasing all of her
music oh yeah she changed one lyric that
everyone was like mad about yeah there
you go
sometimes some time ago little person
matzah
that sounds more offensive and I'm sorry
I know I'm not in that community and
it's not my right to say what about like
Mazel matzah
it's not about I I understand that but
you know for the sake of saying many
people are saying many can you say
munchkin because that's more of like
that's like a Whimsical creature from uh
Wizard of Oz Munchkin is an offensive
well I guess calling a little person a
munchkin would be offensive but I'm
saying like just change it to be about a
Wizard of Oz Munchkin
people are saying mini matzah that's not
bad
[Music]
we'll take you to the board and we'll
rewrite it give it some time micro
matzah we can Workshop it [__] I don't
think we should just yeah this is tough
nobody ever said told me hey dude you
can't say that what about all these
words murder you say N word N word no
that's m word m word N word matzah what
the hell is wrong with you bro you just
got here
murder porn wait what's what's m word
no Trump the m word
um so let's see here yeah I always I've
been thinking about this Colleen thing
so if you look back you have Colleen
her best friend
what's his name
Corey Corey her ex-husband Josh they
were all three having inappropriate
relationships with
kids and teenagers or teenagers whatever
child pornography I wouldn't go that far
Howie that's that's quite an accusation
to put out there that that that I
disavow that I'm not gonna read it
[Laughter]
um but is it just a little
what's the chances that three people
separately are all decided to have
inappropriate
relationships with minors
they're all like-minded individuals
they find each other
do you think that like Colleen maybe
normalized it
I wonder
she they all had to like get their own
team of weenies
because they all kind of did have
their armies they all recruited people
into their own private chats dude so
weird it's entertaining
you got the Corey's clits
the Colleen's queefs hmm
and went the choline cookies the choline
queefs Colleen's weenies
so no cookies for you sin Jared's and
sin Jared Josh Shin Josh
send Josh
um
let me see if I can write YouTube yeah
are we trying to do the CD baby stuff
I've been yeah I'm going through the
process like I'm genuinely curious how
easy and effed up is this to do you know
talk to me baby
but it but how do you explain that
everyone else got released but ours
how do you explain it
somebody clearly said not you
you you you
not you
that's what happened
you proved it and I I frankly don't know
that her lawyers aren't lying
maybe she claimed them all and was like
all right it's not worth it and the
lawyers come out be like my client is
innocent of all charges
my client did not have sexual relations
with those children
that was a Bill Clinton thing but I took
it too far
there was no accusations of that
um
you know
there it is
anything else
all right well thanks for watching
Everybody cheers my dude
the song was on Apple music for a minute
yeah okay let's be honest she would
never have posted this with this image
right yeah the cover is horrible she
wouldn't have done that right
isn't that the cover of the video the
thumbnail
thumbnail and albemar is so different
you think you would do that it's just I
mean it's kind of hard to customize like
I don't know
so you're saying maybe maybe it doesn't
exclude her yeah I mean yeah it says
copyright Colleen Ballinger
according to pop crave uh now the song
is gone on Apple music
was it for sale for 99 cents or
something do we get sales
I'm not sure honestly I saw some people
saying that because it was 10 minutes it
was 9.99 but oh
because it was listed as an EP
yeah oh she wouldn't have done that no
no it's just the length of it made the
made the oh that's automatic I think so
oh my goodness ten ten dollars
yeah so I I don't know I don't know what
to think pretty disappointing though
pretty psychotic uh either way the thing
is this is never I've never seen this
before where somebody put out some kind
of viral meme or song and then
somebody started claiming everybody like
if this was possible to do which we'll
find out via Dan right now
I feel like we would have seen this
before already
you know
um but anyway as we checked the CD Baby
I do I have been going back and
reminiscing
I don't think listening one time oh did
you [__] Mr Beast come on dude
not now
interviewing three of Colleen's victims
Mr Beast covering his ears
I think you really should listen to this
I I didn't I didn't know Mr Beast was a
huge Colleen Stan he's like I don't want
to hear it I can't hear you damn
been there
oh he's even on the shorts thumbnails
the one with the Pearl you couldn't
answer this simple question
um dude I I I'm 100 percent
serious when I say we should actually
try this
it's right on the Highlight yeah
anyway what I was saying is um
I don't think that we played this enough
and I've actually I've been bopping it I
want to hear it again this is banned on
fire hey everybody
it's been a while since you've seen my
face so amazing so I've been doing so
great
it's giving like such a beautiful soul
song when they do it
that I'm almost I'm cool with this
version being on Apple
[Music]
to release it
Apple under Ethan Klein apple apple
uh toxic gossip Train by Ethan Klein I
mean then I'll start I'll start claiming
everybody oh yeah
[Music]
so good
and you didn't deserve to die she hit it
this is how the song was supposed to be
sung okay I would have forgiven her if
it sounded like yes that's what I'm
saying I made this little I forgot to
mention a few things but they're not big
deals
okay try to claim like Michael Jackson
Thriller
you know Dan says it was just ten
dollars to do it
what oh that was a b yeah the album on
pop crave said it was ten dollars on
iTunes that's awesome yeah
my brother's a pedophile
freaking appropriate I don't want to
hear me I want to hear them
listen there's nothing wrong we did
nothing wrong
especially that time I made kids put
tampons in their mouth to take a groupie
photo with me not a big deal what's with
all this gossip nah
come on I thought I was talking about my
sex life with kids trauma really not get
to the good part shut up Ethan as long
as it's entertaining
[Music]
let me do this
yes what she did with that was great
[Music]
it's extra special
you guys wouldn't understand anyway oh
damn we got a guitar solo the worst
thing the least worst thing about it is
the inflation part
nothing wrong with a little
gassing up
all right guys well thanks for being
here we've been gone for two weeks and
we got so much to talk about I thank you
all for being here and I look forward to
having a great show
yeah I don't know about you guys but
this has been stuck in my head
yo
that goes so hard
but hey
but I love them they were so nice too
I hope we can work together again with
them soon
lovely so there it is
uh were you able to uh publish it Dano
I'm almost there
uh it's looking like it will be allowing
me to not only publish it but to publish
it
on
your existing uh Spotify and apple music
really
yeah it uh it doesn't make you verify
it asked for an ID yeah of like it says
you know apple and Spotify will have a
unique ID so that
music from the same artist will be
grouped together yeah you want to use
that I said yes and then I had already
put your name in Ethan Klein so it
suggested it was like we found an
existence and you just click it and I
just clicked it that's that's psychotic
yep that actually I wonder
somebody needs to answer for that yeah
it's not good I don't know if it's
possible at all I think pop or not pop
craves cdb baby
well I haven't fully gone through with
it yet let's see if it actually works
but it would take about 24 hours okay so
I guess we won't be able to find out in
real time well let's do it we could
update everyone yeah
yeah
so that's where we're at on that
what do you think though about Colleen
where's she gonna go from here
do you think she's gonna come back
to take a break at least I think she'll
come back you do yeah they always come
back these people or addicts
and vlogitis she will not be able to not
post well like once you're used to
making millions of dollars just [__]
posting the internet like you're not
gonna go yeah but all the people like
Olivia will still watch every video even
if it's just to download it hello
I'm not saying it to like crocheted you
absolutely is he wrong though uh I can't
you will definitely when she uploads her
next video you will rush to go watch I
wouldn't okay when she posted hi I
rushed obviously to go watch it if she
posts a vlog for the first time I will
here's what I'll do I will go to Reddit
and I'll watch someone will upload it
there she doesn't get my click you'll
want your bootleg okay I'll watch it
so apparently according to her website
the tour is still on and this this is
something that really interests me
actually if you go to each show if you
click on it individually they're all
canceled oh all of them yeah oh
okay wait these are old ones let me go
to like the one in September
no performance
oh [__]
so this is all this is every single one
you checked oh my goodness
she has a podcast too
relax
she did I don't know if she still does
okay so the tour is over wow
you know what's funny her own you the
ukulele video ended the tour for real
finale because before the uke video she
was still touring the ticket sales were
there
was all happening
and in fact I mean I was excited to the
extent that I thought maybe some people
could see that performed live
if she's smart she'd do that she'd take
it on the road that's right yeah just
that one song ten minutes it's a whole
EP apparently yes
all right well moving on I guess uh
Colleen
it was entertaining
except for the serious Parts I just want
to hedge my bed there come on that's not
very interesting is it some parts were
entertaining some parts were serious we
laughed we cried
joke we had we did fart jugs
we've done it all so moving on to Goofs
and gas let's see uh
apparently our okay you guys seriously
want me to do this this is the first
thing
oh [__] now I haven't watched this but
I've heard about it so this okay
removing butt hairs using Nair cream
visual guide
now this video has 28 million views
don't scrub through it real quick I'm
just going to show screenshot there it
is let me see what we're talking about
here okay I'm gonna open his uh
Mr Beast not again
Mr Beast removing butt hair using Nair
cream all right Mr Beast I did not oh he
it looks like The Nair caused a bad
reaction
[Music]
how to safely shave your pubes what did
you put your pubes in the foam box of Mr
boost if you have yeah we can't show
anything if you're hovering over them at
like autoplays parts of it and
oh so he he actually just today he
published a I'm sorry about the Nair
video
oh well seven hours ago yeah it's fresh
we can watch that after this wait did he
do a Colleen thing with the guitar
the only guitar oh it is it's a Colleen
thing
Mr Beast approves of it but check out
the I think his last one was how to
douche your butt a detailed God
how to safely shave pubes keep your
mouse away from the thumbnail so I'm
trying I'm trying the uh I will look
through his videos and uh dare I say the
more graphic one is how to shave uh your
ass
yeah how did wait how did douche your
butt how to shave your pups where's how
to shape which one if you sort by
popularity oh okay yeah
yeah well so Nair is his number one hit
how to douche your butt from 10 days ago
dude he's crushing it two weeks ago was
it these are the top three videos on his
channel how to shave your pubes how to
douche your butt and how to but remove
your butt hair with nail cream
yeah whoa I think Dan needs to talk
about how this came on our radar to
begin with it's pretty interesting story
that we've been found out about oh yeah
I mean this has gone viral the last few
days but the way that we were we were
hanging out on 4th of July
and I got a DM on Instagram from Arab
world news
Arab world news who I talked to in the
DM sometime he's a great guy and he gave
me this hot tip he said have you seen
what I'll tell you exactly what he said
it's so funny it was the Fourth of July
I think I think
in Saudi Arabia he may have risked his
life to bring us that he's an Egyptian
he doesn't live in Saudi Arabia oh he's
Egyptian yeah okay and he uh yeah he
sent hello Dan hope you are fine with a
heart very nice and then just linked the
video
uh Nair on butt I said I think this
story may be deserving of watching it's
a global trending in this time but also
it's disgusting laughing face and then I
watched it for a second and realized
what he sent me we all threw it on the
TV
the TV when you get it at Ian in Sam's
Place when you get a link to YouTube
your expectation is that how bad can it
be
yeah yeah well I mean the title in the
thumb I figured it would be something
goofy but I I yeah nothing could have
prepared me nothing could have prepared
me so I haven't seen these uh you were
talking about how to shave your butt
that's his fourth most popular yeah that
that one he shows uh dare I say worse
and what do you what would you say Beast
is uh thoughts are on this one
he's
I hope he's cool with that one he looks
a little bit
um oh here's one from one month ago how
to safely finger your butt right so he
doesn't show everything in all of the
videos
okay here's my here's my thing I know
that YouTube's leaving it up because
it's educational but
it's obviously not educational right I
mean do you need a guide how to narrow
your butthole it's a cream you just rub
it in there it was very informative I'll
watch it you know what I'll watch you
know what and I'll gauge yeah I'll gauge
so without further Ado I'm going to be
clicking removing butt hairs using Nair
cream a visual guide
here I go Ian you ready
for reference this is how hairy my butt
is right now oh my God
no
no it's awesome
just out of the game it comes out of
nowhere
here's my [__]
oh my God that is more offensive than
the prolapse
that is worse than the prologue no it's
not I'm picturing you go from your text
with Arab world news to this tab yeah
and just like the juxtaposition between
the two that's crazy it's [__] up this
is hold on I'm this is four seconds into
the video Yeah lucky doesn't even give
you chance he doesn't tell us I mean
it's this is this is not okay he needs
to say okay I'm about to show you my
[__] get ready it's shocking dude
get the whole nine yards I love him I
love him okay I'm gonna keep watching
but so just oh my God if you can believe
it it gets significantly worse oh yeah
okay yeah right this is hard for me this
is hard for me
okay so I'll tell you guys what I'm
looking so he immediately is just a shot
of him bending over just like spreading
his butt cheeks wide yeah and then he
has like half grown [__] hairs and
also his balls are ringing it's
everything
it's get it's gaping [__] balls and
then he's peeking from the side so you
can see his face
speaking from the side I don't want to
play it is it educational all right so
so far enough to squeeze this cream onto
your hand so I'm going to be doing just
that
all right now it says to apply a thick
even layer to cover hair do not rub it
in so let's do that
obsessed okay
and there it seems like a harsh chemical
product should you really be applying
that I've never used it before but yeah
that's my understanding as well is that
it like stings it does Sting yeah it
seems because he's applying it to like
an open orifice yeah it seems that to me
seems anti-educational this seems like
potentially bad advice can you ask Chad
gbt maybe I wonder if he's gonna say
anything about if it if it's safe to use
Nair on your uh what would be like a
more on your anus
can you Matt you know what we need to
not recommend it in your nether region
because risk of burns or severe allergic
reaction yeah that this is not good
advice yeah
Ben I need Ben Shapiro's reaction to
this I need the conservative sphere
before we before we is he is there maybe
a special mayor for this purpose though
this generic Nair he showed the bottles
I I think the cream might be
uh not as uh is there a Nair not as
burden it oughta suggested for down
there
is there an air for down there
there yeah there's like near bikini
cream is this something near butthole
though like Nair on my butthole product
because bikini is like this one is
formulated for around your genitals so
it would have to be
okay so maybe maybe it's fine maybe you
know maybe there's a right way to do it
if you guys are looking to
um
to get educational value from this it is
the pink bottle make sure you get the
pink bottle
not rub it in so let's do that
so he's spreading his [__]
and he's applying cream into his [__]
all around spread open his [__] right
in the camera the cheeks as well setting
a timer for three minutes don't go past
three minutes because I did that with my
armpits like I went to five minutes and
it literally burned and stung so bad so
stick to three I'm gonna go wash my
hands now real fast we have one minute
left so far there's no stinging
nothing's hurting it's all good check
small area like your hair may require
more time so let's check a small area
first taking like my damn paper towel
that I got from the kitchen
understand
his [__] is like two inches from the
camera
it's red wide open there
and it just looks like he's wiping [__]
out of his [__] but it's Nair a
little bit more time okay I'm just gonna
like swipe it because like it's been
four to five minutes and like my armpits
are still recovering from like this
thing from yesterday so I'm just gonna
like avoid that and like just hope for
the best
I'm like God oh my God oh God that's so
vile
so he wiped his ass and the hair is
coming out guys it looks like car it
looks like there's some [__] mixed in
there if I'm being honest yeah that
don't look right to me
okay human he's a human okay fine we're
humans but some teams are too you know I
mean to have some everybody we hide oops
dude yeah nobody wants
so you're telling me YouTube that I can
show my [__] one inch from the camera
here's how to wipe your ass and then
there you go it's educational also how
do how do you get into that genre like
what's your first video what like how do
you take that chance it's crazy well
that's a good question we can actually
explore his channel I'm curious but I
find a compelling too is the audience is
split I mean it has about a 50 50 like
dislike 270
000 likes so this man is
people are enjoying this I mean in terms
of a tutorial it's very thorough and
it's probably hard to find this I mean I
was gonna say like yeah as far as like
is it actually going step by step and
explaining little tricks to doing it and
stuff yes so I mean
but again on the other hand I don't know
if this is really advisable to be doing
in the first place so I don't know and
so
it's a weird line
here's the thing
um
somebody said do you really find this
grosser than the pro Lucy no I don't I I
it was just shocking at first
you know unlike the prolapse which is
just a photo
no there's what no the video the
prolapse video oh oh that one right
right
you know because that isn't the highest
quality video either though yeah this
this is this is crisp footage straight
4K [__] this is the Spielberg of
sphincters oh man when we were trying to
find out
it's like horrible [__] so I guess the
point when you're looking for tutorials
you can find anything if it's
educational it's horrible stuff on there
like show me
just Google what's worse than this or
just Google like Nair tutorial and oh
God yeah every single video is whatever
oh Jesus yeah wait so is it hmm I'm
saying there's a bunch of explicit Nair
tutorials on YouTube because that starts
to seem like it's just a a little it's a
loophole a loophole purposely being
that's what all these people are doing
that's so um there's like educational
quote unquote
uh porn on YouTube that's just what this
is
um and this is like a clean side and I
just swept it again so
clearly it's working folding it again
this is like the last of it this is how
my butt looks pre-rinse and pre-shower
and post hair removal cream
okay let me go back and actually I want
to rate this I mean that's not bad
foreign
it's not a very even clean though he's
got like bits of hair all over the place
they just say before this is pre-shower
though
why did I need a pre-shower scorpion
chair is saving me a lot of a lot of
mental damage right now because the you
can't see this directly in the line of
sight people are saying just below it I
cannot you guys oh you're saying him
just blurt take a shower and clean the
area and come back and show you what the
results yes let me see that clean up did
my nighttime skincare this is how my
butt looks post shower post rents and
post hair removal cream
what do we think
let me get a nice crisp shot here oh god
post shower post wrench it's just so
graphic hair removal cream
and then he's scooting closer
but like I feel like eating ass has got
to be one of the hardest things to force
someone to do
um that's vile but actually did a pretty
good job I'm not even gonna lie three
minutes for that that's really good
oh why he's fuckering his [__] he
didn't need to do that damn watch this
and tell me this is educational cream
watch this watch the [__] look yeah
okay what are you talking about I gotcha
that's not educational he literally was
his [__] was breathing
like this it did like this oh Lord
[Laughter]
oh Emily says who's this for I have a
hair removal King okay
there it is
seriously there are some hairs on my
cheeks still like stray hairs but like
overall I think we did really good and
to be honest I do agree with you I think
this Nair hair removal cream did a
really good job at removing my butt
hairs I got this at Target oh he's it
was literally just like ten dollars it
is called The Nair body cream hair
remover it comes in like this one oh
this isn't the sensitive one see I think
YouTube has grounds to to remove this
yeah
here's an interesting uh Super Chat that
just came in from somebody it is
educational there are types of Nair that
are for pubes by the way there are a lot
of baby gays out there who literally
don't know how to do the things he
teaches I agree with the second part of
what this commenter just said but the
first part I think you just pointed out
is not necessarily true because he's
he's not even using the right cream this
is bad advice yeah
okay so here's one that I get what
you're saying I get that there is an
educational value here but this video I
don't necessarily Buy Okay so this one I
think is gonna have a lot of value to me
all aboard this one is how
all right how to safely finger your butt
I sent a short of it yeah that's safe
for work
wait seriously mm-hmm
okay fantastic here how does how to
properly finger your butt first thing
Ian can show this
yeah if it's if did you click it from
Discord
yeah yeah 175 yeah 54 seconds I am not
trying to show this stuff just hit the
button if if there's a mistake okay you
got the button yeah first poop before
this will make the entire experience a
lot easier and a lot cleaner you could
douche before if you want to but that's
not necessary two clip and file your
nails you don't want your nails to be
long and you don't want your nails to be
that's good advice entering your butt
three put some lube on the finger that's
going in your butt position wise you
want to finger yourself through the
front like past your testicles instead
of like through the back like as if
you're wiping like we don't want that
going through the front past your
testicles allows them this is proof that
I did not need to see his [__]
to match the natural alignment of your
butt slash rectum when you're pushing
the finger in remember to unclench your
butthole by telling your mind like I'm
going to poop on my finger
actually the device
okay so that's the short version that is
actually educational now let's watch the
video and Ian please switch off
now let's watch this man fingering but
it's a really good way to loosen up
before sex more specifically receptive
anal sex more specifically bottoming
more specifically taking dick up your
ass you may already know loosening up
before having sex is like the number one
key to reducing the pain that you
inevitably will feel as a bottom when
you take the ding dong up your butt so
this is very important I'm looking for
the tutorial the visual I'm not saying
for me but for sex as a way to get me a
Lucy goosey and I thought it was like
fun and fresh to have somebody else do
it for me but I don't think this video
that like wait I'm impressed man he
didn't do it
at least I'm not finding it by
um scanning the timeline yeah I don't
think he does oh man what a so there you
go you know
there it is
you said but yeah I mean if I guess if
you just type Nair here let me try that
Nair don't show the results removal
because I ordered it earlier and just
the thumbnails immediately were okay so
here well Mr Beast is luckily covering
all the oh it's all this one guy so
here's a thumbnail of a [__] in the
[__] uh thumbnail
there you go
Nair
um let me type narrowing genitals
narrowing genitals tutorial
oh golly
yeah golly hey I gotta see this one hold
on
oh God this one is called Waxing
step-by-step male intimate waxing
2.5 million views the music is
definitely oh Lord work with a supplied
version are you seeing this yep
and it's perfect I know I couldn't tell
what I was looking because the dick and
the balls are like taped together
it's like a try it's like three balls
bro
why are they yank it ooh he's bleeding
he's bleeding tucking your dick between
your legs
YouTube's crazy for this oh my God
preparation in terms of your but this
one frankly is I I more
I'm more willing to give this up it's
clinical as an education than the other
guys gaping [__] well I think that
one I learned more from this one it
feels Dr E because there are gloves
involved right the gloves the gloves
are they aggressively cleaning the balls
and like hitting the dicks okay yeah if
if I'm getting waxed and the waxer is
like like playing bongos with my balls
look at this
look at this it's a lot it's a lot he's
playing like uh what was that game in
the playground where you hit the ball
around the oh tetherball
look at him handle those things boy
what the [__] he's stretching it like
taffy
the skin can feel a bit warm what
happened here like look at this
what is that
I don't I frankly don't know
all right I gotta get out of here yeah
let's get out of this
I gotta get out of this you guys and I'm
sure if you guys can't even see it but
that is okay well shout out to The Nair
guy he's having a moment shout out 28
million years should we watch his
apology or or whatever yeah
[Applause]
ukulele can somebody screen it I want to
know if I can show it right now yeah
how long is it it's short
it's 242. I'm sorry Nair seven hours ago
it doesn't seem like it uh he's just him
with a guitar I think yeah here we go
wait
oh [__] wait wait don't show Ian do I
need a button
because he just did a hunger FF I think
on the back wall
um
should we hit it to be safe no I I don't
think there is I'm looking closely at
him now
he's a Taylor he's a Swifty
all right I think we can watch this I
think we're good yeah we're good yeah
oh he's got a beautiful voice
beautiful voice beautiful butthole
that's true yes
[Music]
we're gonna get claimed Again by Colleen
so he's saying I am not apologizing for
narrowing my [__] yo if you wear an
attack on Titan
I like them
yeah he is
he's a real one
okay there you go he found a niche I'm
happy for him
it is age restricted at least
um there's a really cool new um button
animation I wanted to show you guys come
on oh yeah who made this uh by uh
it has their water from Sam
citrusan
I love these
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
so good
thank you
we'll be adding that soon new Jared Leto
cringe just dropped I actually saw this
on my uh explore page on Instagram
now this man you know I'm not the
biggest fan of Jared Leto you guys know
that
he's kind of a cult
uh he's he's very odd
very odd
he's 51 okay uh understand that as you
watch this
it's got his music in it but
yeah
so
he's
life is beautiful it's like a life
beautiful before and after
[Music]
oh boy this man won an Oscar apparently
comments were calling him Buffalo Bill
oh so true that dance was spot on with a
jacket
those Silence of the Lambs
I'm sorry man but this is that I mean
this is the ick if I've ever seen it
the town brother
I need a machine gun
hmm
I don't know
yeah I like Jared though he's he's
interesting you do I mean in the sense
that he's Jared Leto cold you know the
meme about blue eyes where it's like oh
my God girl we see them close your eyes
that's exactly what I think when I watch
the second part of that he's like look
at them look at oh do you die from me
here is a Jared Leto casually leading a
flock of young women
all wearing white on a private island
time my dude you know just normal stuff
right
yeah come with me my flock of children
literally the dude being a dude Jesus
called his followers children I call you
my children because you are children
that shot right there is straight up
Jonestown yeah
he's just weird how does he get people
in his cult he's like just weirdo
I guess his eyes huh beautiful eyes I
don't know
beautiful eyes
good to be handy beautiful
when you're beautiful when you're born
attractive you can just make a call
this guy has like no he's like so odd
beautiful
he just gets to make a cult
that's it
yeah I don't think beautiful people
understand the blight
that average and ugly people go through
on a day-to-day basis they don't sorry
beautiful they're just living their life
totally oblivious look at this guy he
really thinks he hit a [__] home run
when he was born on third base that's
what they say
no dude you're just handsome that's all
that's literally it
okay
stop
not impressed
that's it thank you
all right love you ready for the spicy
chip moment
all right so we've come to this stage of
the show where um Love is basically
going to become one of us in a sense I
think we could call this hazing loves
hazing I'd say so you wanna so how this
works previously come sit next to me are
we set up for that yeah yep okay perfect
let's go the Love's Gonna come join me
up here in the hot seat
what we have
is the infamous
spicy chip challenge
you got a Pepto I don't know about the
coke personally your pulled the mic up
let's talk about Michael
all right I'm not sure about the coke No
Coke
I think the carbonation will [__]
hurt yeah maybe I'll hit this right now
though okay but you don't want don't we
have something else for him
can you bring the chips I'm gonna bring
the chip too yeah hit the Pepto for sure
that's [__] weird you had a yeah it's
not good but it works and you ate you
had a good meal would you had a good
meal I had a steak salad good okay
fiber let's get this moving along we've
got some meat salad some sauce yeah I
was surprised you see you eating a salad
when I came in today yeah it's weird
yeah I had to eat it last time too
because I thought I would do it Monday
so I've had two salads this week pretty
bad
I gotta eat some Taco Bell after this
oh my God I don't know why you gave me
two of me just in case I don't know I
don't know what you're trying to say
that's what I'm saying we need more
there's got to be more for you yeah
so um very careful don't touch your eyes
after you touch yeah yeah we need gloves
also open over the table so we don't get
any crumbs on the floor
because of the doggies yes sir all right
so
lots of motion around the office we've
got the ice cream vanilla soy ice cream
are you a non-dairy guy yeah no lactose
I'm lactose intolerant do we have soy
milk or oat milk or something wait isn't
that that's milk how are you gonna milk
it out okay I can see the ship we'll get
you non-dairy I have witnessed this ship
it doesn't look good
okay here it is okay so
yeah you can maybe you don't have to
take it out yet but okay
yeah
so um are you good with spicy food you
know I'm I'd say so I'm pretty good with
spicy food but okay I've heard it
doesn't matter I mean it's so so
ridiculously spicy so yeah I feel like
it's on like if you like challenging
yourself too yeah yeah yeah okay I feel
like
I feel like well I feel embarrassed to
say things because I'm I'm gonna cry
soon but I feel like I'm I can't take it
pretty well
but I don't know I feel this well you've
seen uh I mean yeah Elena of all people
these are the champion Lena do you want
to go head to head with him perhaps
right seriously Lena says she'll do it
okay let's go dude
holy [__]
you know what guys
I would totally do it but um I haven't
had a meal right and I'm just be honest
the last time was that was like the
worst pain I've ever felt in my life so
I'm curious do you do you have a theory
about song ships being less spicy
because the first time you ate it you
weren't you didn't hit it that hard or
didn't hit you that hard but second time
it hit you really hard
that's true frankly I don't know I would
say no because they're all just so
coated up right right but um
but it's possible but I I doubt it I
doubt it so should we wait for that you
know let me advise you do not hit this
coke okay hit those hit the almond milk
yeah
so Elena's joining us well how should we
do this because should I wait to see if
he's gonna beat me beat my record
because if not then so what was your
record
I think six minutes six minutes you
think you can do that I don't know I
mean I I'm I can't I don't know what I'm
dealing with here right right so
I might start to cry so um I guess let's
see how he does yeah
at the same time Dan and I are setting
something up one sec if you want to
let's have let's see if you want to do
it afterwards okay yeah
yeah I was just drinking straight from
the bottle yeah
are you nervous no I'm not nervous no
lean is an animal people yeah she's like
ready to eat another one though for no
reason
we gotta like make you uh
chips and salsa Lino where you dip this
into some some habanero sauce or
something some ghost pepper salsa
dude it looks gnarly now can I take this
in one bite you think so so here's what
I recommend you can take it out oh wait
do we have gloves for love
I've I didn't see any gloves back there
okay so just really don't touch your
eyes
okay so take it out you go take it out
oh we have no gloves that's what I'm
hearing we don't have gloves
I didn't see any back there
all right that's fine but go ahead take
it out okay so that piece broke off when
I and what I do is I break it into small
pieces so you can do it all at once yeah
I personally you don't have to do that
you could take it in bites I think it's
easier just to get it off sure and if
you don't want it to touch your lips or
anything right
yeah this is a good good size right here
that's it are we ready uh not yet not
yet
could you could we get a wipe or
something for his fingers yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna need some
we don't have gloves my friends I'm very
sorry my fingers are already like
you're coated yeah I'm coated
do you want to just touch your tongue on
the powder just no no I can't do that no
absolutely not that'd be awful
I gotta hit it in one go and then I want
to suffer so that didn't do anything
else okay yeah
okay that is not funny so we go
uh-huh what what thank you Lena Lena
brought a wet wipe and some towels now
here I'm just gonna move this here so
eat it over the table yeah just so
there's no crumbs because my doggies all
right um we're waiting for Ian and Dan
are preparing something how's the pool
house love how's America
I feel I feel bad because immigrating to
America
is probably really really really hard
for people for idiots and losers but I'm
living in like a pool house I'm eating
dinner with your family every other
weekend you didn't feel bad we welcome
you you're our you're our honored guest
no it's nice and I'm boring people don't
know that but I'm borrowing cars we have
a van yeah that we bought for Teddy
fresh for like
just whatever yeah and uh we don't
really use it that much so love has got
he's got our
it's just someone it's like a white van
yeah it's nice it's nice I've been
enjoying it it has like cruise control
oh what's the car in front of you yeah
it's like I'm kind of just relaxing nice
nice
yeah so let us know when you guys are
ready we have the timer
the record to beat is gonna be six
minutes six minutes that's pretty far if
you beat six minutes we can have a Taco
Bell party well Dan actually has the
record a little higher than that wait
dan be it Lena yeah holy [__] as it as
it stands right now Dan did it after us
because he didn't do it the day we all
did it
so Lena you can you can try to retake
your your record after this no matter
what because Dan has the record
currently yeah I'd love to beat him so
what's Dan's record
I don't remember I'm checking right now
okay Ian's looking all right well as we
look love
I'm ready all right whenever you're
ready go ahead we're ready back there
yeah I'm ready I did seven I just
checked and seven seven so so love has
the mound of chips he's and we're
starting the timer from the second he
starts eating yes all right
cool I'm ready go ahead whenever you go
go so the chips have entered Love's
mouth now before it starts hitting you I
would recommend cleaning off your
fingers
get them nice and clean really wipe them
off
I mean yeah yeah I think we said it was
okay to have something to help swallow
it down I would wait till but we waited
till we swallowed it naturally we just
took one sip I thought yeah you can have
one but really wipe your fingers off
focus on that you don't want any of that
[__] left over
so love is crunching so far he is
just
um
he's just getting it down focusing on
the mechanics of it yeah
down oh it's down
that was pretty good time to get it down
I'm feeling the hiccups already feeling
the hiccups your eyes are watering a bit
now you can take one sip of oat milk if
you want or or uh yeah just to like wash
down because there's lots of little
crumbs in there now I can't promise it
helps because I feel like when I did
that it made it hotter
potentially you got this dude you're
doing great
it's not that spicy in my mouth okay I'm
not going crazy
wow my hiccups are gone
it's no I I feel no pain what you're
talking to the mic
I feel no CR crazy pain about this
hiccup
it's hitting me pretty hard now I've
seen other people get spicy hiccups I've
never had that uh before I get rid of
them
even when you eat casually spicy food no
no no casually bombs talking to the mic
sorry the mic please sorry I'm a bit
distracted yeah man that's
understandable and um it's not hurting
no what not that bad
yay
seriously I'm good you're fine you can
go forever
yeah
because I think it Peaks around two
minutes right you are just passing two
minutes right now yeah wow wow those two
minutes cruise by
yeah I think I can go forever
it's not hot at all it's very hot don't
get me wrong okay
bomb because it wasn't hot at all I
would say we had a defect yeah that's a
duck got a dud but I'm just breathing
focusing yeah literally a tear fall down
your face yeah
but I'm
I'm at peace
wow it's not your fault you're at peace
I think I'm good if you want to go to
the next level rub your eyes really good
I'm sorry to say it but I think I'm good
wow
you're a Shad bro I get what Love's
saying because once you reach that
threshold and you've you've done it
already it's like you can go forever
it's still spicy but it's very very hard
in my mind yeah
you want to do another one [__] no
making me sad my body is craving
something to drink I will tell you three
minutes it's just really dry
it's a very dry chip that's what they
get how they get you
yeah but your face your your your words
is not matching with your face tears are
running down your face well both that
was kind of the thing was down right
didn't you say you found peace but you
look yeah but I had to actively seek
that piece out
right you know
physically I feel my body not liking
this at all but my mind is
about every time I see this this milk
right here it's like well you only
there's only what another gosh three and
a half minutes to do
[Applause]
I'm good I can say I don't need to drink
ever
I don't need to drink ever again in my
life
I need something better to wipe my hands
with though yeah can we get a wet uh
towelette or something
but I don't want to like I'm not like
trying to act cool it is super hard
submissible
my throat is hurting
more than my mouth
well I could I couldn't act cool there's
no acting if you can act cool then
you're cool right I want to wipe my
tears away though
wipe your tears away do you want me to
dab your tears off your face sure hahaha
dog sip gossip don't go close to my
mouth though
there's a little dab because we don't
want to mess up the makeup
you just get the the trick is to just
get the tear duct like if you get it
just one tip I've learned this from
Trisha I think yeah if you start crying
you just do like that you just soak it
up that makes sense
love you love y'all
I'm good I think I'm good holy [__] man
that's that's that's incredible he's a
warrior I mean what the hell just
happened cheers feel like we need
spicier food
yet though like sure how's the toilet
gonna look like after this the toilet
frankly wasn't that bad no even even
yeah I disagree it burns a bit but it's
not as bad going in
oh okay we're gonna pop so Olivia
brought us a because my hives are like a
little bit blue still yeah I get those
yeah I want that to be gone yeah you
know you you saw wash with soap
afterwards no I can't I don't
I I could force myself not to drink
during the whole show you could go the
horse you don't have to do that
it's at some point so does that mean
we're having a Taco Bell party that's
frankly why I did it when you said that
it's like dude all you got to do is pass
seven minutes
and for every 10 seconds past seven
minutes you get another chalupa no I
don't know I'm just kidding but love and
I've been talking about something else
what oh we've been skiing
after everything we've been through you
still want Boba everything you've been
through I love Boba I thought you turned
on them
80 grams I think that I was feeling a
little bit um
singled out in that convo I think I
still love Boba and I think that love
being here is making me a lot I want
some Forever on the Boba train brown
sugar I'm out boba's overrated you
haven't tried brown sugar milk to you
dude I have quite frankly no they're all
so sweet I'm trying to diet but dude
I've been telling you over soon for a
long time you can get like 50 sweetness
yeah or like 25 or just say no sweets I
agree there's somebody needs to hone in
on this a little bit I think we need to
start ordering from a different place
all right love you guys for that you've
got basically uh at this point 10
seconds 10 seconds yeah I won't drink
after that either well you you can set
the record for as long as you want oh
yeah I'll set it for like a couple hours
or something
I think at a certain point at eight
minutes I think it's probably probably
be about I think over seven you're
probably good it's technically the world
record you've got the record I'll keep a
golf ball a little bit so what's up dude
you want a Taco Bell party or Boba party
boom I have to pick yeah it's Love's
pick yeah if you want to pick one you
can come do a spicy chip Olivia because
it's not meat today it's about love if
you want Boba Party come get up here I
order eight
the salad right yeah yeah and I'm scared
like am I gonna puke later I don't think
so he'll hold off we can do we can save
your credit for like oh really sure but
I won't yeah I don't want to disappoint
Olivia oh my God no no do not worry
about me you're don't worry about her
literally the pain you're going through
right now let's hit the [__] bow
button you want Boba yeah hey
well I'm sorry to I feel like I didn't
put on a show but no you put on the best
show dude I just watched the show it was
great yeah whatever you made a cucumber
yeah so I mean at this point Lena was
gonna go but I I feel like this has been
demystified the three of you guys
there's a trinity of u3
because it's unaffected I feel like both
of you guys could have gone for way
longer if the number was higher yeah
that's true yeah John when I did it when
I did it I passed Lena's and then we
said we were like let's just go another
minute to raise the bar and then I'll do
it but I I probably couldn't just hung
in there for a while longer right now
the person we really need to get back up
here is Av
foreign I feel it brewing in my stomach
though
thank you he would give give us updates
as uh the digestion I won't drink for a
couple minutes just to
okay and then at your desk we prepared a
cup of FICA juice for you to drink [__]
that I ate the fish once tried to onto
the show you remember that I don't
somehow figure for life that was bad so
you have to sit in his room I remember
right and like stunk up your place yeah
your dad was pissed yeah he was really
mad
all right wait so was there another
challenge we wanted uh the fika one he's
done the Hot Chip he's done
uh what else have you tortured us with
over the years I don't know which sounds
great possibly I can think oh yeah Sam
toothpaste casserole oh the
that one haunts me more than anything
she's ever made that was the most
disgusting thing Zach you base Zach you
still have the opportunity to be fully
hazed as well I'm cool brother
is so bad on these things is it supposed
to be blueberry or something no it's
just no it's just [__] it tastes
horrible yeah there's no flavor all
right thank you though all right well
done all right am I keeping this clock
going
are you drinking he hasn't drank yet
would it be dangerous to do two chips
you want to do two chips Lena no I just
don't no I don't have this one
the bar needs to
need because we are not Lena come sit up
here
do we oh we have a bunch of these we do
have more than one remaining so now Lena
says what about two chips I think it's a
good idea you know because you've
correctly identified
uh
one is just not enough anymore well at
first I asked is it dangerous I didn't
say I'm gonna do it for sure is it
dangerous well there's a warning on here
let's see do not if you're sensitive
spicy food allergic to peppers
nightshades are cap sand
if you're pregnant
you better reach your children wash your
hands it doesn't say anything about
don't eat two chips okay I'm none of
those things though
[Laughter]
we Dan our love would either of you be
down to do that compete with me no I
think love needs a reason yeah I think I
think gloves needs a minute but you can
you can be the first world record for
the double chip and this is Joker brand
I mean this is what it is doing to
actually make the spiciness worse I feel
like all that does is just make the
stomach part of it worse because there's
more of it in your stomach but I feel
like when I did it my mouth was fully
coated in that powder I don't know what
another chip would be I I have an idea
you do one chip and then after a minute
when it's hitting you the spice then you
do the second chip you know that would
[__] you up I mean yeah re-upping later
I guess
Lena have you been eaten today oh yeah
have you eaten I had a bagel
if this puts me at the top of this
category just this category I'll be
happy okay yeah all right she's hungry
okay so here as the as the boss uh here
I say uh absolutely yes no I'm kidding I
say don't do it don't do it that's my
advice
but uh since you want the record and I
do think you're deserving of it I don't
want the record here's the problem it's
not right that love and dance should
deprive you of the record that you
earned and I do want to say I only
stopped at six because we're like okay
doesn't seem like anyone's gonna pass
this let's just right right exactly you
haven't had a chance to respond I think
that's totally fair I I
I still think you should just do one and
pass passes but it's your call I see the
point though it's not is she's not going
to have any title just doing one at this
yeah because I can go like 10 minutes 15
minutes and then love will still beat me
exactly or Dan yeah well love has
disappeared
I'm chilling I'm all good oh wait right
you're sitting here
it's chilling
I have not stopped the clock the clock
is Israel you haven't drank yet no I'm
just proving a point at this point I
don't all right well the lean is about
to prove a point oh yeah we're doing it
so it's up to you I mean if you want to
I'm here for it I do do you know do you
want to eat something do you want to get
some Pepto-Bismol in your stomach maybe
Pepto yeah I'll start with Pepto so I
don't think love touched any of that if
you want to uh do you want milk I don't
think he touched the milk no that's but
that so that is soy milk do you want
cows this is fine could I mention
something I did not even take a drink to
swallow it and that I wow if we're going
like if we're going I don't think Lena
did either actually I don't know yeah I
didn't either I don't think so
yeah Elena is like she went like she's a
champion dude yes she is so are you
ready to do two right now love I
honestly I feel capable but I I'm scared
of what would happen in my stomach
that's the only issue okay so now that
we have two Warrior competitors here
let's start with Lena okay I just need
some Pepto should I go all right so
let's can someone grab Lena some Pepto
yeah and we need another chip it's over
here
um let me just basically dispose of
these chips here
okay
are you okay with this baby you want to
say something Abby
the lips
you you whatever you have to say go
ahead
uh yeah I'm worried but uh also I've
seen some comments saying don't do it
after lip filler
but where did you see that
I'll let me Google that or chat GPT
but it's healed your lips are fully
healed
food after lip filler I'm not sure they
I
another food to avoid after your lip
filler or spicy food spicy food color
blood vessels in your lips to dilate
which can lead to bruising or swelling
you must wait 24 hours it's been one
week yeah so you're you're fine I think
okay now AB is there anything you want
to say to her
you sure you want to do this yes she
seems pretty sure
here and then let's let's make it
interesting
after she eats the second chip a b just
a peck on the lips for good luck
I like that idea
no I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding
I'm not gonna I'm not the like the Willy
Wonka of [__] Amy's life up
oh my God I need Lena to be so I know
did you see the trailer for the Willy
Wonka movie what why
oh I mean that's a good question it's a
prequel haven't you always wanted to
know the origin story of how he built
the chocolate Empire
no it's not have Johnny Depp again in it
no it has a t-show
hold on I want to see a picture
uh Willie show me Willy Wonka it's
called Wonka okay dude you guys need to
chill Charlie on the Chocolate Factory
the first movie is literally such a
masterpiece truly one of the best films
ever made why is it Warner Brothers
that you can't just [__] chill Harry
Potter was come on
no
this Christmas huh
I don't know about it why does it look
like it's set in like
it looks like it's in Harry Potter
what if Willy Wonka's um he's amazed
he's a wizard yeah that would explain a
lot explain a lot yeah
all right Lena so here's the here's the
uh game
and love this is this if you want to go
for the title this is what you'll have
to do sure so you hit one chip
after one minute
you hit the second chip okay that's it
fair enough I can do that now let's now
here hold on let's you guys is everyone
okay with this I wanted to ask what the
audience any objections yeah is the
audience is you guys okay with this yes
or no say yes to Lena's right to reclaim
the title on her own terms do you want
me to do a poll yeah no I'm scared for
Lena
no she doesn't need to do this
can I just simplify it to should Lena do
this yes or no yes okay well not sure we
know she shouldn't no you know what I
mean then what are we asking then we're
staying
um Lena do this that's a bad poll sir
Lena do this
you're a wizard Wonka
you nervous no really
yeah but not really I feel like the the
in a sense
after you conquered that first ship
something changed in you
like when Spider-Man was bitten by the
radioactive spider
do you believe that that I felt that too
yeah well I just it was kind of
underwhelming because I thought it would
be worse dealing with it and it wasn't
and like love said I felt like I could
just go hours so I am worried that your
stomach is somewhat empty yeah that's
what I'm scared of too I see love
looking at me I'm worried about you he's
worried about the title no I don't know
I didn't want the title this was just a
the I wanted to do for the show I did
not want to go I want to kick back
something real fast no I think I'm fine
I think I'm good she is very confident
what can you do what can you do all
right let's let's just make our own
decisions I just need one more chip we
need one more chip uh can you grab one
please
okay let's do like this so I can easy
clean up just open it over yeah
so I oh yeah yeah I'm gonna use a
different stopwatch for Lena
so I technically can keep loves going in
the background here
loves is still going I'm at this point I
can go for just have a drink although if
we're if we're calling the double like
does the double chip just automatically
put you in a different tier yeah yeah
like even just doing like a minute yeah
right so then I guess I'm not gonna
drink though there's no point just
because love is just not drinking till
tomorrow yeah he's fasting yeah to prove
a point but why you can love well I'm
just
I don't need it I'm not thirsty okay
he's good he's chilling love Kapoor man
now is it is it because he's young
because I'm old now I feel like when I
was younger I could do dumb [__] like
that so certainly my spicy tolerance is
not crazy but my pain tolerance is
pretty high and I feel like this went
over to okay your pain tolerance is high
I can use that yeah yeah
I can use it oh yeah no for real do that
oh what about the pregnancy things yeah
we should do the spicy during the
pregnancy I wanted to do that yeah let's
do the period simulator bring anything
on let's do the chip and the period
simulator at the same time sure [__] it
would you do that now uh I don't want
you to I want to see how this impacted
me in my stomach yeah no that's that's
wise and Lena also conquered the uh the
period simulator
I remember you were just laughing yeah
that was so cool it was tickling I did
it didn't hurt it was horrific for me
like I I was
all right
um to to all the Warriors what did they
say when the before the Warriors fight
in the Coliseum they go to those who die
about to die We Salute You
something like that
just go for it it sounded right let's
take out
the free set it up so all everything
okay that's one chip damn that one looks
real dirty that is super coated isn't it
yeah
very powdery okay this is kind of pieced
up but that's okay
okay so let's just so we know let's
start here
and then after one minute you're gonna
go in for the second one so Lena is giga
Chad Lina is going in
someone said you guys are evil listen I
I can't we all tried to talk her out of
it
she suggested it yeah and by the way
y'all Lena do this 71 whoa thank you
guys the people they believe in you they
do Lena is so cool somebody said you
know I feel a bit bad I I can even go so
far I'll keep let you have the title I
this was just a thing for the show not
to compete with you I'll let you have
the title if you don't do it just saying
what yeah but it will always be yeah
yeah
I don't want that I will always have an
ass she doesn't ask I'm revoking it
Gladiator said this before battle I
don't know if you want to say this it
says I will endure to be burned to be
bound to be beaten and to be killed by
the sword I will be endured to be bound
to be beaten to be by the sword yeah yes
wow
okay today I guess that's in a sense
that was like the ancient wave saying I
consent to this I consent to this this
is for you guys all right Lena whenever
you're ready you sure yes
she's literally perfect
oh Olivia you're perfect oh my God are
you doing you're gonna do two separate
pieces yeah okay but of the one chip all
right here Lena goes
bolina's got the first part in oh very
gracefully inserted didn't touch the
lips at all probably a good call
stunning he's chewing yeah no you
there's no rush you can take your time
to get that one in there
she's got like a whole meal here
chewing
I just want to choke she doesn't want to
choke and that that's definitely good
advice too I also don't want to take
your take your time on that her husband
you don't want to be suffering more than
the last time already it tastes bad
right it's the flavor yeah the flavor's
horrific
hey she got that one right in there good
job well done all different flavors so
you're not grimacing at the spice you're
grimacing at the disgusting flavor yeah
you might want to wipe your hands now
too right can we oh yeah maybe on the
there's a towel yeah what
and you wash your hands love
uh yeah I tried still blue
there's lots of support for you in a
chat people are saying we love Lena I
love H3 girlies Lena's a legend we love
her
oh
oh it's okay he paused there as if uh
something was gonna happen but
is that hot
yeah okay it's hot it's hot but at least
she admits it you know
She's coughing oh oh you can't take a
sip let's get it down uh sure sure yeah
yeah yeah so I don't go for it go for it
man is just taking a small sip because
it is very dry it's very dry yeah and
that means love you you'll you'll be
able to compete under the same position
sure although you don't believe in
drinking right no drink
okay so that seemed to hit you kind of
harder than the last time perhaps yeah
are you sure you want to go on to the
next chip I don't know okay wow this is
hitting her different yeah what changed
wait I do wonder if some chips are
spicier than others I mean you did say
that one was like coated in the powder
the powder is what gets you thank you I
mean that's the spice the Lena is
actually going through something right
now oh
all right just need a minute and I think
I can you can if you want you can rally
you can rally I mean it's your call at
any at any point
so Lena is actually having a moment here
yeah the last time Ela was seemed to be
less affected and it begs to the
question are some chips spicier than
others
um
yeah that puts everything in the
question doesn't it
[Music]
we just turned this whole competition
upside down well you got two and a half
minutes so whenever you want to move on
to the next chip up to you you don't
have to
no I think I'll be totally honest this
one looks less coated yeah
maybe another sip just it's dry I don't
think I could chew it okay
go ahead
this is your record so however you want
to set it
you need a couple sips
there it is
that's the bar okay
how are you feeling now my mouth is on
fire and you still want to do that
I'm warning you when you eat spicy food
on top of spicy it's like
exponential spice yeah
maybe do some ice can I get some ice
this is how I felt yeah now I feel for
you guys now okay
oh maybe I could just put this
oh God
that's my that's the one I use for my
hands oh no can we get another Direction
hold on get it away from your eyes are
you sure I'm not sure about this second
chip right now this seems to be like a
good idea
okay we got a whole bag of ice can we
get a paper towel
are your hands clean you good on that
front
all right so Something's Happened Here
um Xena is getting hit pretty hard from
this this is helping okay ice on the
head yeah that's perfect that's the
perfect way to go into the second ship
well maybe
oh if you look I'll start with a half
are you sure you know you know yeah that
still beats the record right
you're a little messy at this point yeah
I mean a little messy but I'll let you
do it I'll let you do it yeah but 70
people believed in me I have to no you
do not everybody's proud of you yeah I
don't feel pressured by the audience
should I do a poll
yeah why don't we don't care new pool I
don't care about football I'm still
gonna do it
no but why so if you're gonna do it why
eat half
I mean I'm gonna try with half at least
yeah
okay
why
um to win to win anything to win a true
competitor not like anything but
it's something I think I can do
right but last time you didn't have ice
on your head yeah and you're drinking
like non-stop oh tiny sips just because
I'm going for another
Lena's bending yeah
listen I I well I don't want to come
down
nobody expects the extra credit if you
decide you don't want to do it you know
what I mean you're good like you already
got an A plus the audience turned now
it's at 61 percent whoa I'm scared for
you I'll do it for her no no no no
that's a bad idea
I don't want him to do it well this is
entertaining at least I mean at least
we're on the edge of our seat here right
absolutely yep and we do not have
paramedic standing by yes as long as
it's entertaining
they're standing by I just have to call
911.
do we know how close the closest
hospital quite close is quite close okay
two minutes should I should do
this at any time if you hit a second
chip I think it's impressive yes exactly
even if you did sip a little bit but I
am worried that first ship hit you hard
I mean that's just one chip look at you
you're a mess I am nobody sat there with
me the giant ice back on the head that's
correct is that okay though it's fine I
just I've never seen
I think I'm just nervous of the
anticipation of the second but I can do
it
oh I totally believe in you I think you
can do it too Bob thank you love I'm
worried I just feel like it's possible
the the human organ might not be able to
take it not Lena specifically no it's
not like that you're not gonna dish
you're gonna die yeah but I'll say this
love the next time you attempt this I
think we need to open like three chip
bags and select the most [__] up
looking chick yeah because there seems
to be this is the conclusive evidence
there's a difference in chip
chip spice
this one is less [__] up yeah so I'm
just gonna go for it do it I'm not gonna
are you sure I'm concerned yeah yeah I
can do it you're feeling okay now I feel
better a nice hat on you know what that
is that's the ice Crown because you're
the queen thank you
she is the queen yeah there's nothing
wrong with putting ice on the head I
think she the chip was kind of her thing
and she's fighting for a title but
there'll be other challenges Lena for
you to win I like this one
if I were to challenge again at some
point
what would be the guidelines for like
drinking yeah it's kind of all over at
this point it's kind of like
just eat two chips and yeah if you
survive yeah yeah it's hard Lena it's
not worth it because yeah it's dicey no
no I I agree with that that just do two
chips it has been eight minutes
because I feel like at that point it's
dangerous to have another without having
taken a slip a few slips
because you can't chew it and swallow it
so I'm just gonna do this
I'm not I'm not gonna physically rest
stop you
but I will say
okay
Millennium worried you're so tiny that's
the thing your stomach is so small I'm
just gonna do it
Elena is fighting for her title a sec
her body has said no but Lena has said
yes she has put another half chip in her
mouth and she's chewing
she is
um
nodding seems to be okay for the time
being
got a giant bag of ice in her hand she's
going in she's gonna do it
you're there already
you're it's just like you know I'm going
it's like going in for a an endoscopy
and they're like let's just do the
colonoscopy too while you're here and
you do it you do it because you're there
already
and she doesn't need an endo Scorpio
she's in and then I mean there's just a
few more crumbs you're practically there
he seems to be in pain now she can also
spit it out if she if she wants to
yeah of course he could do anything no
I'm telling Nina yeah
I don't know that that would help though
are you regretting
no she's not regretting no regrets a
second no regrets a third a fourth piece
and that that'll do it
I won't make you uh lick the crumbs no
wipe your hands oh no a gag
oh
you need a spit should we get a trash
can
just know I do have a trash can stand by
stack please do you have you ever pooped
are you puker I have before okay you
don't feel nauseous
how are you feeling you feel okay or
yeah hotter than last time or so no this
is oh [__] she just gagged well that's
spicy
you says it's not as spicy
she says it's not as spicy
okay I did it
you definitely did it
the ice is back on the head
I could drink yeah yeah I mean this is
your game this is your rules
he's drinking the uh
there's ice cream there
right so we have we have a third chip
I'm kidding okay God damn true Gladiator
right there thank you literally the
strongest in the world where's the heat
level compared to the first chip not as
bad no not as bad wow I think once your
mouth is coated you know in in the spice
you are hyperventilating more is really
adding too much more spicy you're
breathing heavily what's going on it's
it's just hot but
it's tolerable and tolerable
okay tolerable is good we like taller
yeah
I feel good you feel good you feel good
well there it is we're gonna set the
standards
yeah no cheese thank you guys
the spice queen with the iced tiara
is there any kind of party you would
like to have uh in celebration I offered
love a Taco Bell party but party for
Olivia
's literally the best the best so let's
we can have a boba party and then you
can still save your Taco Bell party
credit let's go that's nice Friday
[Music]
awesome okay I'm gonna go to the
bathroom now okay totally what are you
gonna do there
just uh compose myself okay
that's all what
you want I want AV to come no no
um okay guys I'll check on it okay yes
and thank you uh thank you Lena yeah
well he's out here uh breaking records
incredible give it up everybody give it
a competitor what a competitor
okay let me just move this stuff off the
table
[Music]
what a show
Dan says we're only just now getting
started too
what
all right
let's see here
Lena is so strong
I can't believe it childbirth will be
nothing to her she'll be like I'm ready
for another
two uh love as well who hasn't drank
I've been watching him
honest over there have a drink for
Christ's sake man I mean I I don't feel
anything in my mouth now or anything in
my stomach so I would say so don't feel
obligated to not drink like I feel like
you you got over the hill and we're not
even timing it anymore I know I know I
just drink when the Boba gets here yeah
I'm not thirsty that's why I'm not
drinking
better you don't want any of that trust
me
are you ready come say hi
nope that was a little scary no nope
are you playing Diablo I don't uh Dan is
anyone playing I haven't I haven't even
no I topped off there's too many I I
didn't even play it I'm planning on
checking it out at some point but I
don't know just the end game is a mess
is it it's just not it's just that
the devs are so annoying it's like the
heart the bones the soul it's all there
but the dev development of the game was
just lazy
um it's like well it took a couple years
for Diablo 3 to become a good game so I
know but wow why do I have to wait
that's not how you make a game
stupid you're playing uh Necromancer
right I I started a barbarian oh I got I
mean how many hours have you played
at this point I don't know I mean a fair
bit you think you're over a hundred
over a hundred
close to it close to it yeah at that
point I mean it's a 60 game I feel like
you got your money's worth like it could
be better but like you think about what
Diablo 2 was you guys made this
masterpiece game and you didn't learn
from it you just keep making worse games
I don't know yeah I don't know think
about that I haven't played it
extensively I can't really even comment
on it I've been seeing a lot of that
online though of people being frustrated
with the end game and that's always kind
of been my attitude is it's like
the game is getting old for you at 80
hours well then maybe just play another
game I mean that's 80 hours from a
single game it's a lot I feel like yeah
I I every game I buy I count a dollar
per hour right exactly yeah I feel like
that's a decent ratio yeah look
I'm I played it obviously I'm not like
regretting my purchase I'm just saying
like how many hours did you get out of
Warcraft and Starcraft yeah I mean
thousands I mean that's what I'm saying
like that that's the difference yeah it
could be one of those games maybe
there's a little more effort maybe in a
in in a year or something it'll uh
that's gonna be able to improve it by
the way the Barb so the Barbarian is so
much stronger bro it's fun I'm like
Invincible it's also too easy oh really
like I thought I went to Torment level
three all the way and it's like yeah I
can go to the dungeons that are like
five levels above me and just melt
everything yeah so go hardcore dude
yeah you can't look away you can't have
kids you can't have a life yeah I don't
like nothing I mean now we're talking I
have kids that's right so that already
right against it so you can't enjoy the
game too it's fullest potential and then
like they have these World raids which
are fun and cool and I love the concept
but they're too [__] easy I agree
with that they're so easy those are dumb
I don't know it doesn't make you know
that's it that's my review of Diablo
thank you
I just wanted to come here
do my thing for this show nobody's
blaming you all right it's fine well you
know she wanted she she she's got the
competitive Spirit she's gagging oh no
that can't feel good coming out no it's
bad because I burp just now I feel it
coming back up I hate to say but um I
have to remove the title if she puked
like it's got to come out of the
butthole not the mouth it's not sadistic
it's just
does anybody care about the rules
wait oh no
I feel bad I hope she's okay baby's in
there with her yeah yeah he's attending
for it somebody said review tears of the
Kingdom great game love it you beat it
right beat it nice fun game I played it
with Theodore we played the whole game
together
he was super into it that's a great game
to play with the kid and then so we we
played
tears of the Kingdom together we loved
it then we played um Mario Odyssey all
the way through oh that's fun loved it
and we tried that one
did he play in the Mario no he's not
he's not up to the controller yet how
old is he he's four
get him I'll try I try I'm borrowing at
three
right but it was it was just left and
right when we were kids that's true the
NES controller is a lot simpler I I TR I
give him every opportunity and he seems
to just want to he likes watching yeah
that's fine so then the next game we
just started which seems promising is uh
Luigi's Mansion oh he'll probably love
that one we start I was very
kid-friendly I'm actually surprised how
um spooky it is it's spooky it is it's
quite spooky it's like Haunted Mansion
spooky right yeah it's not like
genuinely scary it's like fun scary you
know I've never played any Nintendo
games really at all I've ever really
owned a Nintendo console yeah there's a
reason they're popular as they are
they're great games yeah I'm probably
gonna buy the switch
which has been a good system yeah
all right well as uh let's see loves Cav
update
with fousey update wait there was oh the
Jonah Hill we should do that
because we've been wanting to talk about
the the Jonah Hill stuff and I don't
want to run out of time you know what I
mean
you know what I'm saying well speaking
of
running out of time there's another big
segment hmm
to do today oh [__] the dancer
the Jan the dance The Bachelor
um but we could do that on Friday if you
I I just think it it will take a while
hahaha
okay let's that's the audience
we'll do whatever you guys come on you
want to do The Bachelor
or do you guys want to do the Jonah Hill
messages now that Jonah Hill stuff is um
getting old I don't know
but whatever you guys want to do
well I think that we have passage on a
hill thing I'm sure we could talk about
other things too I just think the
bachelor
we really should have picked an easy one
the dantula uh I think it will take a
big chunk of time and we'll probably be
ready to wrap up by the time it finished
so we could just save it for Friday and
we can just do other topics today let's
let the people decide I want to give the
people what they want Jonah Hill plus
other topics yo what's that Mario RPG
come out yo wait actually they're making
that they're re they're re-releasing it
oh you know so you don't know Mario RPG
is one of the best games ever oh really
back on Super Nintendo it was so
freaking good what are you roaming type
thing no it's like an old school jrpg
but dude wasn't that game it was so fun
you know what I never actually played it
I I know that it has a great reputation
and I've played a lot of those types of
games but I never got around to that one
oh wow the people want Bachelor Bachelor
it's actually pretty close it's it's
actually moving now yeah
so of course back the dantula will do on
Friday
if not uh today
it would give us good title for Friday
the damn right because we already have a
great title today yeah literally
um back
so it sounds like maybe I'm thinking
maybe Friday
Dan picks his dream chair
Dan nears his butt I am eager to do it
just because I don't know you will not
see that on this channel I am eager to
do it just because I want to get rid of
this [__] chair but um
well but for the good of the show we can
we can wait till Friday it's actually
moving significantly it's 52 back uh
dantler yeah that was 50 50. it's fans
of Jonah Hill gossip get your votes in
I'll be back 49 Jonah Hill gossip back
Jonah Hill
back
I'll be on your back in a chair
finding all these back dude that's
beautiful Zach thank you it's I gotta
tell you it's more my legs
I see my legs that hurt sitting in this
chair more than my back yeah yeah
between your legs okay Jonah Hill fans
it's evening up it's 50 50. let's do
Jonah Hill let's do it and we can hit on
other topics too we're gonna do the best
I don't think it's gonna take that long
on Friday
worry not my friends
yeah Mario RPG to me it was like one of
the first I think RPGs I played as a kid
and it was like so fun it was so
ridiculous yeah I'm excited to play this
remake just because I missed it when I
was a kid like it was such a perfect
turn-based RPG it had no reason to be
too it's like Mario game
was so good
yeah all right so let's talk about our
boy Jonah Hill
now I don't know if you guys remember
but he is a close personal friend of
mine and friend of the show I saw him at
Starbucks Coffee uh the Starbucks
parking lot once
did you say hi does it mean either we're
pulling in we were parking to go in he
was coming out oh no way and we locked
eyes did you really we lost I made eye
contact we locked eyes and he looked to
me as if he
devastating for you then
it hits her even harder than Justin
roiling
I shouldn't even joke about that
um there was a slight glimmer of
recognition in his eyes and I thought
really Jonah Hill
is a fan
oh you think he recognized you maybe oh
yeah he's a fan right
[Music]
and ever since that day I actually put a
lost connections ad and Craigslist were
you looking at him with the exact same
expression with recognition could it
possibly have been a reciprocated like
what
no it wasn't no no I'm sure you knew you
were famous it was like this look how
cool he is now
it's all tatted up look at the cup
the cops and he's claw Machining his cup
no it's falling to the ground
oh what a dork he dropped his coffee
when he saw it he's such a [__] loser
wait hold on dork I thought you were
cool like what the [__] dumbass there's
nothing more embarrassing than dropping
the coffee idiot do you think he doesn't
even realize it's happening look at him
he's like looking off things his day
he's going great you don't give a [__]
dude now as an actor I'm a fan I like
his performances
what you and Kanye both yeah she solved
anti-semitism
but uh no I do I like him I mean wait
what
Kanye said that he likes Jews after
watching his latest video he plays a
Jewish character who's dating a black
girl
got it I kind of remember that now yeah
yeah
I guess
right here oh God this is getting maimed
so
I'm into my surfing girlfriend I mean oh
okay
so here we go let's get into this now
this whole gospel but you guys what you
guys don't are fans of his acting I mean
I thought everyone liked him like
Moneyball he was really good like his
movies I I enjoy his movies he has the
most insane watch collection too like oh
outrageous really yeah super bad during
the Jump Street I mean super bad he was
amazing he was so funny well except yeah
so it's a little different
Jonah Hill is he I guess he he actually
is a writer too I think he has a lot of
writing credits on
he's worth 70 million dollars why are we
talking to him now well no we're
listening I'm just I'm just being honest
right I'm setting it I'm setting the
stage yeah and I'm I you know I'm just
gonna lay it all out there okay he's
worth 70 million apparently that's crazy
it's kind of is he tall too uh let me
see him I don't think so I think he'd be
more Rich honestly that's kind of what
100 below a hundred million
I think I think 70 million sounds about
right for his degree of success wow he's
leading actor in a bunch of big movies I
mean okay he's five seven so he's quite
he's on the shorter side okay dumbass
idiot idiot poor jeez
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's got sexual about it I didn't say
that I thought you said horror
I just realized what happened I was like
I just felt like I called him a [__]
right [__]
that's funny so um so before all this
came out my sole impression of him was
that I liked him okay also I really
appreciated his weight journey I mean if
from super bad he was really really
quite big
and his journey to becoming like active
and um
losing so much weight was was pretty
inspiring
I mean listen
this this photo
was like the meme photo of the year
the [__] neckbeard photo
like he's come a long way man yeah
no doubt he's very lovable though in
this like I don't know
Batman good Batman good
this is I mean this is No Shave November
expectations versus reality
uh
I yeah so here it is okay
but his beard looks good now
right
look how I'm showing people images it's
fine
okay so anyway let's get into the story
so Jonah Hill
was dating this girl who is I guess a
she's a pro Surfer
and I had seen photos of them together I
knew they were dating apparently they've
been broken up a year though I didn't
know that she's a surf instructor
so she's a professional Surfer she's
yeah yeah she's a surfer and she yeah
teaches people too and I know Jonah Hill
took up surfing too which I suppose is
probably how they met
but what the [__] do I know
so Jonah Hill's uh ex-girlfriend a year
after their breakup
posted
uh a lot of their DMS to Instagram
stories accusing him of being a toxic
partner
I think it was emotionally abusive two
years ago
not the most important detail but well
it is kind of important it does make me
wonder like
broke up two years ago Jonah Hill I see
they yeah 2021
Islam okay
uh she's with a B can someone go check
on her yeah I can go
I just want to know that like
for December 2022 that can't be right
that sounds right to me I remember
seeing them together like recently
oh apparently he's got a new girlfriend
with like and he's got a kid with her
that's why I'm saying it doesn't make
any sense December 22 is she okay baby
Amy says I think so
okay excuse Louise man some like purple
stuff just shot out of her nose oh
wow
your nose is really hot right now holy
[__]
[Music]
holy [__]
it's that blueberry that is
horrific did she perhaps fly too close
to the proverbial spicy chip
as it possibly yeah
so in that year span he's has a kid with
somebody else no way that's what I read
okay stop
America early 2022. yeah you said
December 22. no I read that I was
reading the sentence as I was running
and they made their debut in December
and split early 2022. got it yeah yeah
my bad
oh yes
um so let's just get right into it so
her name is Sarah brat Brady
and uh here she is let me show you her
Instagram she's a public figure
she's a surfer I'll show you pull this
up
she seems cool
you know
he's a sir also it's important to note
how she dresses because one of the
problems he had with her
was that she thought he thought she was
dressing too provocatively
which I found interesting upon reviewing
her instant page because
I mean it seems if anything she's
stressed a little on the more
competitive side yeah she's wearing one
piece I agree yeah as a surfer on the in
the beach I mean did you know what I
mean 100 percent
so certainly
oh she's a law student okay
so here we go let's go
album of leak DM so this is what broke
uh The Floodgate here
sharing this publicly now
because keeping it to myself was causing
more damage to my mental health than
sharing it ever could
so she was yeah okay
[__] it so here she goes she's dropping
the texts
here it is from him plain and simple
if you need
surfing with men
boundary-less inappropriate friendships
with men
to model
to post pictures of yourself in a
bathing suit
to post sexual pictures
friendship with women who are unstable
I love that
I love that she can't be she cannot be
friends with men and also women who are
unstable
I mean who are in table places and from
her wild in recent past
I am that woman well he says she can get
lunch or coffee with right but we can't
do no nightclubs we can't do a wild
recent message
he says if any of these things are true
then I am not the right partner for you
if these things bring you to a place of
happiness I support it and there will be
no hard feelings
but these are my boundaries for romantic
Partnerships
my boundaries with you based on the ways
these actions have hurt our trust
see the misuse of boundaries so
I want to discuss this a little bit now
when I first saw this
obviously horrible toxic insecure
boyfriend
but at the same time
he is saying like you know listen I'm
crazy he's basically saying listen I'm
crazy my expectations are insane
and if that's not right for you then you
know we're probably not a good partners
which is yeah you know I mean that's
crazy his expectations are completely
unrealistic and psychotic he says don't
model
don't be don't surf with don't surf with
a bit she teaches surfing for a living
don't surf with men
that's crazy he's he is asking her to
basically just be just be like a
housewife or something he's an actor
you can't you can't
yeah no no T no working with girls
for Jonah but at the same time
he's saying like yeah I'm crazy
these are my expectations which are
horrible mm-hmm
so like
I guess my my please don't get mad at me
guys I'm just being honest
my snap judgment from all this was like
I just don't know that she needed to
share all this that was my snap judgment
okay
don't kill me please
but let's keep reading I just feel like
uh if you think yourself in the
situation where if you have a sister or
a daughter or something in a
relationship like that I feel like it
might change the perception nobody here
listen he's saying
my expectations are crazy and if
should anyone have to like no no
yeah
no nobody should have to do that but
like I mean
I see kind of what you mean though
like I just but let's move on let's move
on okay so let's see I'm just being
honest
because it's such a it's such a uh
it's such a violation of his privacy
it's
it's such a strong powerful crazy
like this is the utmost invasion of his
privacy
and so my my thing was like is this bad
enough to Warrant that level of breach
of privacy and I wasn't sure about I
wasn't sure I thought maybe it didn't
arise to that
but so let's continue
I'm just being honest okay
I listen I agree it's disgusting right
what he wrote is [__] up
I agree
nobody should have to live under these
kinds of rules it's so insecure it's
disgusting
but
he's kind of being upfront about it he's
like I'm [__] up
I'm a needy [__] up I and he has a lot
of damage clearly he's got a lot of
issues
coming with this list
and he probably has a ton of baggage
from being like super big being at
school growing up that way you know that
causes a lot of emotional turmoil
so clearly he's very insecure
very
so anyway
yep like kind of unbelievable that a man
who sent me [__] like this
so here he is
um
how you doing good I want to see you so
what is what am I seeing here that he
was that's how he became interested in
her in the first place
which is ironic
so my my
opinion changes slightly as I go through
these okay so one if he he found her
because she's a surfer and then to
expect her to stop doing that as they
date is pretty [__] up
he would then be upset I didn't read his
mind and take down pics of that once I
was in a relationship with him
okay this is just a conversation with a
friend I guess yeah so here even the
person I loved and shared a bed with
uses me and can't just be like yeah you
were super nice it hurts so badly but
I'm done apologizing I was so lovely to
you I don't know the context it was so
lovely to you he definitely wasn't love
leader yeah I was such a nice guy
and I agree it's giving mad and so yeah
yeah it's straight up giving fresh and
fit well I you know what I'm saying like
I can't agree more that he's just a
human walking red flag
but that's not that's not the point I'm
making right Chi being our couple's
therapists at the time she had me agree
to paddle away from any man that
approached me in the water I mean that
that's insane crazy
duh man I'm gonna need to break
those eggshells no matter his age a 13
year old boy ah get away my boyfriend
will be mad I know boy shark ah he she
was instructed to say I'm gonna go talk
to my boyfriend and then battle it I
mean it's almost comical how obscene it
is yeah and that was the couple's
therapist that suggested that apparently
which is kind of hard to believe
is this like a psychologist uh couples
therapy like what which who's the
couple's therapist exactly
my advice to you is just not to complain
anymore sweetie
that makes me want to go stab someone
wow who's this therapist she was
enabling his possessiveness yeah it's
true
uh she was she said yes that must have
made you feel crazy uh I don't know why
she's releasing DMS of her talking to
someone else about it find the odd
he instructed us to come up with safe
word for when Jonah was yelling at me
that's scary wait hold on hold on
I'll talk to other men so what does she
mean she instructed us to come up with
this oh so if he's being too aggressive
yeah she says pineapple which is crazy
that's bad yeah
pineapple you need a safe word in an
argument yeah
like that why would that work if he's
angry enough to be yelling yeah that
doesn't assume so I mean this this part
here seems
yeah
pretty bad pretty yikes it's pretty
pineapple
can we use that here
icky to see how I took the blame for him
cherish she is apologizing to him
I'm sorry I said that I had a couple
beers and I'm just upset feeling like we
can't do surf social things without an
uncomfortable situation Rising that
usually feels like it's my fault
I feel you pull away and then the
feeling of being defective Creeps in I
think I'm not socially intelligent
enough to meet your needs as a partner
and then I get frustrated and angry at
myself
I just want you to rip the Band-Aid off
if I'm not good enough for you in
moments of conflict my brain thinks you
want to dump me because I'm not good
enough for you and you're the goat
and you can do better and you
immediately once you end things with me
you're right we can't do surf social
things or develop trust until you
consider me and make decisions that give
regard to I mean he's [__] nasty
you know
okay
and I know it's it's easier said than
done but he is like I'm crazy and if
that's I don't know I don't know
literally it's just I feel like you know
what I mean but I feel like him being
crazy is not an excuse not to share it
also no no it's the vi it's the
violation of privacy has it dude I mean
this is this she's ruining his life with
this essentially but for example that
message before that uh where she
apologizes I feel like that's a great
example of
why it's important that it's shown that
this is not okay to other women for
example yeah that's all and out there
thinking this is normal it's also just
he's saying to her look if you want to
be in a relationship with me you're
gonna have to let me emotionally abuse
you and it's like
that's not
that's not necessarily these are all
terrible things in a relationship right
and it doesn't take away from the fact
that he is emotionally abusive even
though he's coming out right and saying
it
I'm my only question
still
and I hate to put this out here because
clearly I'm gonna be the bad guy for
saying it
I just I still not 100 sure this Rises
to the level of public
violation of privacy I mean guys you've
been in a relationship you've never done
something that you're embarrassed by or
that you've never wrote or said
something you're like I regret that that
sounds horrible if somebody I mean I
mean yeah yeah
not like that and and also I mean I
I feel like I somewhat identify with
this ironically because I I had a past
relationship that was uh pretty toxic
that
I I was I was the girlfriend in that
situation I was dating a girl that was
extremely jealous and possessive and
would get mad if I talk to other girls
and that kind of stuff and um
and
yeah I at the time didn't really realize
it until I was a few years out of the
relationship just how abusive that
actually was and like how [__] up it
made me feel and everything
would I
publicly blast the crazy stuff that she
said to me to the world
years removed I mean I personally
probably wouldn't but I can kind of
understand why it's a different dynamic
because that the person I was dating was
not a beloved public figure and if your
ex-girlfriend who was abusive to you
emotionally this way she's like
a mega celebrity right and first of all
as a celebrity dating is so hard and
let's look at Jonah Hill he's super
insecure he's super [__] up super
damaged like
again I'm not even trying to defend
I don't want to defend him because I'm
not defending anything he's obviously a
horrible partner
but there's I just I'm not there yet I'm
not I don't know I don't know some
things something not everything needs to
be I I don't know like I hear what
you're saying not everything there needs
to be some boundary of where this is
acceptable or not like yeah obviously
you know I mean what the [__] well I
think that like obviously she knows way
more than we do just based off of these
screenshots and since these screenshots
have come out we've learned that he is
in fact a dangerous possibly person to
be spending time with in a sexual
romantic way or just in a social setting
is from what the later update said so I
think that it's her trying to warn
people and since it's been like days and
and other people have like some another
person has said something one person
came out which we'll get to yeah
okay let's do this in order
also
I will say too part of the dynamic I
would say is like I haven't seen this
but I've been hearing as part of this
whole situation is that he
made a documentary about how therapy
made him a great person or whatever yeah
also I feel like if I I feel like that
yeah if I were the the other person the
situation and I saw that that might push
me over the line to be like I can see
that let the people know what a [__]
hypocrite this person I can see that
because didn't he do something about
like I'm a feminist and all this yeah so
if I believe it if he's out there like
I'm a feminist and I'm a I'm a great guy
then I'm like nah [__] you you suck
right he weaponized therapy so clearly
in these text messages like the therapy
did not better you it looks like therapy
maybe helped you be more give you some
new language to give you something the
same person yeah exactly
well whatever I don't know what [__]
therapist they were talking to I know
some random a couple therapists that
that suggested the uh swim away swimming
away from men things like I don't know
that doesn't sound like any real advice
a therapist would ever give
so anyway let's just continue on before
you guys um
before you guys uh draw and quarter me
literally just saying hello leave the
combo I love how your therapist thinks I
suck I literally am the best boyfriend
on Earth crazy Christ dude I don't know
if he's being sarcastic you know what I
mean
possibly being sarcastic
he's like no I don't think so I didn't
read that way to me but I don't know
literally just say hello and leave the
combo I love how your therapist thinks I
suck I am literally the best boyfriend
on Earth you could say that on
ironically I mean even anybody who is a
good boyfriend when I saw this
screenshot I assumed that him saying
literally just say hello and leave the
convo is him talking about her speaking
with men in public right that's a crazy
thing that's [__] insane and the fact
that she like thumbs it up makes me so
sad
like that's her being like yup yup yup
just don't want to engage yeah
I mean like I said I feel like I've kind
of been there literally just say hello
and leave the combo I mean okay yes I
agree that's nuts it's insane and it is
abusive I agree it's abuse it's
emotionally abusive the way he's
treating her
why do you love this guy so much it's
not that like
no I think it I think it's a fair
question to ask of like when like how
much this one's in the gray Zone at
least in a relationship deserves to be
aired out I think that's a fair question
to ask in this case
Having learned all the context because
I'll be honest my my I my initial
reaction was similar to yours I was just
like why am I reading this like this is
not my business
um especially the first few texts when
it's just like him but the more I found
out about it and the further I got into
the messages and then yeah I mean by the
end when I'm literally the best
boyfriend ever it's like okay this guy's
[__] so I don't know
also it has to be feel terrible seeing
this guy just doing great and amazing
all the time and like have that within
like jerking piece of [__] he was use
the [__] out of me for years and just
seeing him like you having to keep that
a secret is probably quite a big burden
like right yeah
I mean it was super successful when they
met
yeah
okay moving on I don't care for your
massaging he says you're right
we can't do surf social things or
develop trust until you consider me
and make decisions that give regard to
our relationship I've been vulnerable as
possible and I'm telling you I am
needing you to step up to the plate
which you can I'm sure of it but these
losers don't get your time if you want
me straight up it's consideration
I respect your love of Surfing pathetic
but I respect myself as well and your
love of Surfing and being in those
situations and lack awareness are not
mutually exclusive this isn't me I have
my own issues that I own
if you want marriage and family you
can't use the 25 card what does that
mean
she's 25 I assume oh how old is he
let me look up
step up and cut [__]
25.
these people don't get your time or your
kindness he's 39 right now at the
sacrifice of mine he's 39 yeah
yeah 39. that's quite a big age
difference eh
by these people he meant my any friend
of mine that hadn't personally approved
of I mean this is like next level
controlling and insecure
if if he's mentally ill which he clearly
is to some degree
if the man is like look it I'm mentally
ill I'm not capable of having a healthy
relationship I'm not sure because I'm
not that basically what he told her but
in the screenshot right before that we
were looking at he lists a bunch of
stuff and says this is not me this is
you these all of these problems I just
listed above this these are all your
problems
uh
uh this isn't me I have my own issues
that I own
like he's saying he's doing everything
right she's doing everything wrong she
says I have my own issues that I own I
mean I agree making her feel like she's
doing something wrong by having male
friends is [__] up and weird but I
feel like in that case she he shouldn't
have a relationship if he's that
horrible he's saying she refuses to
acknowledge that she's doing stuff wrong
but he acknowledges that he is
right I think so he says I have my own
issues that I own
but he's saying you being friends with
men is the problem which again crazy
insecure loser
and again it's just that when you find
out the other details about like how
they connected in the first place and
everything when you throw that all into
the mix it really become like you know I
can see
the very surface reading of like well
you know like you said where's my she
was eating something in the kitchen a
minute ago
Lena are you here
are you not
it might be in the bathroom I'm not sure
I checked in with her a few minutes ago
and she was all right he was yeah yeah
what was she eating
oatmeal I think oatmeal okay that's nice
yeah it seemed like did we order Boba or
no no Boba no question
I didn't have time to ask Lina what she
wanted there's been too much happening
oh geez boobies
boobies
we could do tomorrow the boobies all
right
um all right so moving up moving on okay
uh yeah yeah yeah blah blah
that makes me feel like you're testing
me to see if you should keep me around
or dump me because there's something
wrong with me like I'm a nerdy dorky
unaware naive idiot socially I hear you
those are your words not mine okay
whatever
he's obviously an [__] and sucks
this is a warning to all girls if your
partner is talking to you like this make
an exit plan I agree with her
wholeheartedly
right
good start
he says to her you don't seem to get it
but it's not my place to teach you I've
made my boundaries clear you refuse to
let go of some of them and you've made
that clear and I hope it makes you happy
I mean
so because she posted this photo which
is [__] crazy I guess because what
she's wearing a bathing suit
like a one piece getting getting upset
about that is [__] that's next level
with your Surfer girlfriend
that you met because she's like you met
because she's a surfer I mean she really
just exposed what a pathetic loser is
yeah big time I mean you know
like you you guys say defending him no I
looking at this I the guy is he's a sad
pathetic loser I see that now I thought
he had his shift together I thought he
was a cool dude and if these other
allegations that we're about to get to
of validity to them then he's more than
just a sad pathetic loser and I think it
makes more sense loser
somebody said Ethan question you had
Ethan you would not have this opinion if
it was
I think they meant Crowder but it's just
crowded dude Crowder
the Crowder [__] was on a whole nother
level
we can I mean was it
well we just saw a video of it
and also Crowders like the family guy
he's like oh I have a perfect family I'm
Christian values and they're married and
his wife is pregnant well with the twins
and he's smoking and he's smoking in her
face
to me worse for sure this this one is
like there's some gray area can you guys
at least just [__] give me that in my
opinion the Crowder one was like
no crazy but again he's yeah he's a
pathetic loser I mean that's he's not
just a loser though it's like Abu an
abuser this is like abusive Behavior a
loser and I feel like this user is very
close to user
like just little I push you push the
skin a little bit I can't hear I can't
hear go ahead love push the scale just a
little bit more and this would look like
it could be really bad right yeah
feel like it's just something for us
like what it's called crust yeah we're
only seeing what he was willing to put
in writing right exactly and we saw the
indications that he like was yelling at
her and [__] it was probably way worse
yeah like I'm trying to imagine
the conversations where she says
pineapple like I can't I can't even
imagine a conversation where you would
have to put a safe word into a
contentious conversation like that's
really really layered and really [__]
up it's scary yeah and if a friend told
me that was something that they were
doing in their relationship I would be
really really scared the pineapple thing
is pretty is pretty bad yeah
uh
so he says uh anyway he gets mad like
she posted this
is a warning to all girls Partners
talking like this make an Exit Plan help
respect however you want to live your
life you only get one sort of done with
explaining myself
I don't know why he's even trying to
make it work it seems like he doesn't
he's like
treating her really badly right
this is oh same thing three removed not
the video yet
it is my best surfing video would you
feel better if the if the cover frame
was different any more specific ones
that bother you
yes one that isn't of your ass in a
thong not a thong but K and I'll I have
not talking to her about that the photo
that we saw a second ago is this the one
one
yeah maybe it is
because come on no this is like well I
went to her page immediately because I
wanted to see right what I thought and I
haven't seen her wear anything close to
a thong yeah
God he's such a loser
like like what what year is it what year
is it this is like puritanical like uh
this is what
insecure people do I was going to say
insecure men but again I I dated a girl
that this whole scenario reminds me of a
lot minus the uh incredible dude hold on
you guys are already [__] dude you
guys are so absurd Ethan is this how you
treat your wife like why am I why do I
even bother like some of you guys need
to really just learn to [__] listen
to somebody who has a tiny bit differing
opinion than you that's all I'm doing
now you're gonna say oh I must I must
abuse my wife because that because I
said maybe she shouldn't have shared
these you [__] you stupid [__] I mean
what is wrong with you guys some of
y'all are just so sensitive how do you
live your life stop it okay stop
I'm not even disagreeing with you guys
I'm just I'm just toying with this
thought that I don't know if it was
enough
right because we're in this culture of
everything gets shared now
dude [__] you whoever wrote that
why are you even here
but I see a lot of people saying [__]
like that it's like bro what what what's
the point of me even speaking my mind
I knew you guys were gonna be so
annoying about this
um before we got derailed what I said
just you should just close the chat it's
triggering triggering you
well I'd like to be able to have
conversations where I can express
opinions that I know you guys aren't
gonna all agree with you know what I
mean without you accusing that I'm
[__] abusing my wife
um
so she said yes the yes one that isn't
of your ass in a thong she said not a
thong but k
and as far as the other pictures you in
a bathing suit surfing or not not a
thong but Kay he responded I'm done
there's tons I'm just going back past
month I mean yes he's a pathetic [__]
loser
he sucks he's a shitty boyfriend
he is abusive for sure I agree
but now there's new stuff that came out
so those are the DMS she posted
originally they were making the Rounds
Around the internet
all right
Sarah suggests Jonah was manipulating
controlling her that's true a lot of the
alleged texts she posted appeared to
show Jonah was constantly uh yeah yeah
yeah it was just a summary we went over
so here's update after his ex-girlfriend
called him out
then another story came out about him
which is worse
this so This Girl is actually what's
interesting about this is she is or was
an actor
yeah she's a child actor she was on Zoe
101 is that right yeah she played Nicole
on the first season of Zoey 101 and then
she was just not in it starting the
second season
so and Olivia you were explaining that
she had some yeah some interesting drama
with the the stars of that show right it
was yeah she I think summer 2020 is when
she came out and she started talking
about why she wasn't on Zoe 101 anymore
and it was because Jamie Lynn Spears
allegedly bullied her horribly and
apparently brought Brittany on to set to
also yell at her wait what Britney's
sister has since publicly apologized to
her yeah what the hell because Brittany
had a falling out with her sister and
Alexa publicly uh supported Brittany and
Brittany apologized to her for for doing
that oh wow yeah so she confirmed so she
she seems like really credible yes
um not according to uh Jonah Hill's
attorneys well of course say that
everything that we're about to see is a
complete fabrication and never happened
right and Jonah Hill seems like the
nicest coolest guy I just remembered you
know
um uh
uh
Colleen says she she never claimed the
the songs yet
she literally has the same lawyer as
like Army Hammer
yes that wasn't my PowerPoint you
kidding me he has the same lawyer as
prince Andrew Army Hammer wasn't there
another one there is but I didn't know
the name so I didn't put it in the
PowerPoint some real Shooters the state
of Jamie Savelle
the pope Jesus the Catholic Church no
just the church in general
yeah so she went with the big so yeah he
would never lie
right so she said after reading Sarah
Brady's admirable post about Jonah Hill
I just gotta say when I was 16 I got
invited to a house party at Justin
Long's
house
who's just someone was that the guy who
was in all those like you'll recognize
him he's a big actor the Mac guy he's
the Mac guy oh he was the Mac guy you're
right yes what happened to him he's not
he's not really uh he was a new girl he
was oh he is I don't want to compliment
him right now he was like the
the dorky lead with the hot girlfriend
of like a Whole Decade yes yes
he was when when you couldn't get um
the other guy that looks just like him
really a little bit bigger of a star
than him wait who is that I can't think
of his name right now you know who I'm
talking about Joseph Gordon-Levitt yes
he went in for 500 Days of Summer I'm
sure but he's like the Walmart Joseph
Gordon but Joseph is a hunk right that's
why I'm saying Justin long's the woman
Justin long's a little bit of a I mean I
don't want to compliment him right now
is he hunky sure oh I didn't know that
I knew he was hunky he's like Charming
you know Joseph gordon-lev is Jason long
I never thought of him as hunky
or like hunky dory
thank you guys
yeah he looks handsome here
damn he looks old now he just played uh
the loser creep idiot creep in uh that
movie Barbarian there
and he was playing himself I guess okay
so what was he accused of something I
guess so not actually directly just a
betting uh other uh scumbags okay so she
was at uh
she was at Justin Long's house it
happened at his house and he she accuses
him of being aware of the nasty stuff
that was going on and not doing anything
about her age yeah she says he was
living with some lame Predator actor
from CSI Miami
I'll look up the name later he was
sleeping AKA assaulting a minor a friend
of mine wait oh she's accusing Jason
long of that no no the guys oh okay he
was sleeping AKA assaulting a minor a
friend of mine that was also 16 or 17
anyway Jonah Hill came over at some
point and we were all pretty wasted
because of course the Predators were
feeding us miners a bunch of alcohol
dubrick
[Music]
what's the sound that David dobrik makes
as he cracks open a bottle of alcohol
for a 16 year old
exactly
thank you
hey Justin long if I find it interesting
you being in a barbarian as a predator
must have been weird playing some of
your friends you knew your roommate was
assaulting a minor under your own roof
you let it happen I mean if his roommate
was having sex with a minor that's
definitely
that's what I'm saying I really had a
first party accusation but she is
accusing him of aiding and abetting some
nasty [__]
oh yeah this was the guy uh who was
sleeping with a minor well listen if
that's a that's a pretty crazy
accusation like I'm pretty sure that
she's gonna she's gonna get sued for
saying that
possibly
yeah if she can't prove that that
happened she might be in big trouble for
that because she's straight up like
here's the guy he was sleeping with a
minor
good on her
which makes me you know believe her
because that's a risky thing to do
um I mean she has Britney Spears of
credibility
he got that Brittany cosign
the email guy from wedding crashes was
there too
the brother the weird Todd I don't know
that movie that well well enough to
remember that character the type of
predatory behavior was hyper normalized
when I was a kid proud to see women
standing up to abusive men now badass
this guy
this guy who cares about him Todd
Todd you [__] that actor was also what
were you doing there Todd
you know a reading her account I
I understand she goes this type of
predatory behavior was hyper normalized
when I was a kid try to see women
standing up to abusive men now badass
I think that's a good point in that
they're obviously look look who's
friends with Jonah Hill
he's friends with like Leo uh James
Franco James Franco who's like also a
mega creep that guy's like a mega mega
creep was he charged with anything James
Franco is like no but he's like uber
canceled I don't think he's I think his
career is over yeah he's like exactly so
when you look at it like this is just
normal how men act in that Circle it
definitely is a problem you know it's
something that's worth uh shining a
light on
so but again so as I go through this
maybe my mind changes
I've been traumatized by men in
Hollywood it's truly sad the traumatic
events I have lodged my body and mine
things have to change [__] Family Guy
too
now she goes from Seth MacFarlane yeah
which I guess she apparently did a while
ago and it went under the radar from
what I was understanding
also Justin Long why the [__] did you
have children at your house late at
night agreed
so you know like yeah I see it as a
pattern of these guys who are all kind
of abusive and [__] nasty and so
looking at it on the whole
you know I get it
uh just to note Jonah Hill said if I
wanted the Sig
I had to come with him outside to get it
he didn't want to go alone
I was 16 and they were all aware of it
Jonah Hill didn't hand me the Sig which
I thought was weird and then as we
walked back to the door I asked him for
it and he said nothing but slam me to
the door and shoved his tongue down my
throat I was so appalled I pushed him
off of me and ran inside
so that's
that's pretty gnarly that's nasty
yeah he assaulted a teenager allegedly
according to her not us
hey Shredder
was just staring at me
I love you so much
ready puff so sweet and I love it
so cute such a good boy somebody said
James Franco is the only celebrity I've
met and then like a sick looking face
yeah
but so um
yeah I mean look the idea that there's
like this party house for all these like
uh celebrities and then they're inviting
16 year old girls over there that's
[__] really bad and gross
and worth it airing out that is and if
Jonah Hill's a part of that then he
definitely deserves to be getting aired
out so when I see it like um
Ethan I think there's a point you can
concede too
I know you value your privacy and didn't
take it well when T and M secretly
record y'all but that was undeserved
Jonah deserved this and then some okay
well that's what I'm just trying to
that's just what I'm thinking the
conversation yeah you know yeah I'm
sussing out his feelings about it what I
was trying I think earlier to say or to
describe is that like
it all those tax by themselves I think
are horrible disgusting
if you needed more persuasion
possibly I think that it could
definitely be argued that this woman
knows a lot more than we do and it's
possible that she's aware of the fact
that he's a predator
if she spent so much time with him and
spent so much time in his Circle I don't
know well yeah knowing this then it
definitely you know makes me feel
[Music]
um
it recontextualizes what uh the
girlfriend was saying quite a bit to
hear that he has this kind of stuff was
he when she was 16 do we know that uh I
believe in the article it said uh
uh
excuse me allege Hill then aged uh 24.
24 16. yeah that's pretty bad 24. that's
crazy
wait was that Howie saying that no that
was an AI
now that sounded like that didn't sound
at all like we got to work on that
they they're not all great but there's
something uh
Charming about him I don't know let me
hear the 24 again let's hear it 24.
20 oh I hear it a little bit a little
bit late again
24. [__] you now I don't hear it
so in response uh to an inquiry by
deadline Marty singer
any relation to Brian Singer does he
represent Brian Singer I think he does
oh wait no I'm thinking of I'm thinking
of um
Colleen I think Colleen's lawyer
represents Brian Singer I think
let's see I searched his name and
there's a vanity fart vanity fart a very
Fair article
uh title vanity fart oh
uh titled Hollywood lawyer Marty singer
can make any problem go away except Bill
cards well actually he got bill out of
prison man bill is out a ballroom full
of household names John Travolta
Scarlett Johansson Charlie Sheen Jonah
Hill oh oh this was from 2017 so oh God
his lawyer for a long time
um
brettler who is Colleen's lawyer has
represented clients such as uh Danny
Masterson oh that one's really bad Royal
prince Andrew the prince Andrew one is
crazy those are all like the worst of
the worst people are like too bad for
him to represent the last time right oh
no he did build Crosby Chris Noth
I know who that is
but yeah not it's not a very pretty list
that dude from uh the set That 70s Show
what's his name Danny Madison he drew
that guy went to he's going to jail for
like 30 years recently right like or
just straight up like R wording women
yeah crazy Masters
um was he at Justin Long's house I
wonder how this lawyer sounds like he's
morally the best sounds like he's the
best
so yeah obviously I I'm my mind is
changing in the context of everything
uh anyway his lawyer said uh Nicholas's
accusations is a complete fabrication
adding that it never happened
as you know it's illegal for lawyers to
lie
do I believe him
Stinger went on to call Nicholas
a demonstrably unreliable source
and a Serial accuser
who has made assorted accusations
against multiple men in the
entertainment industry well
what are we saying that's impossible
Jonah's ex is now spamming dozens of
young child actress in Hollywood yeah
getting abused by multiple men
it's impossible it's ridiculous she was
hanging out at a house as a six-year-old
with a bunch of famous men I can't
imagine that she was ever abused by more
than one person so now his ex is posting
more and more
of their uh screenshots
do we have one I this is just a tweet I
don't really want to show this to you
uh I can just put an album is there more
than these four screenshots
yeah maybe I'll just show this
a sheet so now Jonah wrote her back and
now she's she's making all this public
screenshotting intimate text between us
is a huge triggering violation for me
and breach of trust as a friend I have
trust
as a friend
I've explained to you about breaches of
trust I have had between trusted friends
recently and I have caused me trauma I'm
incredibly hurt and feel a lack of
safety where I have always trusted you I
bet
he's definitely in a world of [__] right
now I'm being ironic though okay shut up
um I'm sorry if a former partner moving
on is painful and I emphasize with that
but I've done nothing wrong and if I
wasn't a public person I wouldn't face
this kind of violation and having shared
that with you and then watching you be
like this today shatters my ability
trust anybody ever further I've always
been kind and showed you support
again I
again is there any reason for her to be
sharing this
I mean am I crazy
I mean it's tea
I mean that's a good reason right it's
good enough for me
here we are talking about it so I'm just
trying to be I'm just trying to you know
uh a little confused by this though
because uh the date says uh August 31st
wait yeah how does that make sense
that was last year previously share a
bunch of texts and it just didn't go
viral like this wait what that's so
because it seems like it's a reaction to
what just happened but it's dated
August of last year
right
so what happened back then
it's a good question
um that's a very good question
here She is again this is from the same
day but I don't know what happened back
then
um
try to make close as a testament to my
care and love for you I'm sorry you feel
these negative things Sarah but I know
you but I know you don't
you're too untrue and just said with
anger which is fair I'm glad you feel
you get to be your full self and sword
that is all I could ever ask for you
please take care of yourself and I'm
happy to pay for your therapy through
the end of the year Jesus he's like yeah
I know I [__] you up I'll pay I'll
cover your therapy
that's crazy actually
even though you'll somehow punish me
with that gesture but I don't care
because it's best for you be well
all I want in life is to be a family
person to start a family so that is and
will be my immediate goal I respect that
yours is your career and respected
deeply I hope we both get what we want
people are saying typo but I don't think
it's that even typo doesn't make any
sense if it August 31st hasn't happened
yet this year so it would have had to
that would have several typos yeah or
two like everything in that day would
have to be wrong right but wait that
doesn't make sense then
yeah we have to go back to the future
maybe it was just uh between uh
private parties like it had gotten back
to him that she was sending screenshots
to mutual friends or something
what the [__]
impressive turnaround time so he got a
new girl I guess like what like two days
later this is two days after the the
message he got
Jonas Beach romance actor gets cozy with
girlfriend Sarah Brady
can you tell your publicist that that's
not me
so is this the girl that he has a kid
with now
this is her Sarah Brady two that will
choose a wild Mare and then try to tame
her into a docile Homemaker and get
abusive because she's being herself no
his his baby is with Olivia Miller
yeah Tammy you got busy
who is that his current girlfriend
Olivia
um
okay whatever good for them
so I don't know that's about it
and that's all I'll say about that
love ya
love you my homo
cheers my dude she co-owns a vintage
clothing shop with her sister I bet she
doesn't wear bikinis or have male
friends no the photo I'm looking at
she's wearing a long sleeve long dress
that's it he's looking for an orthodox
Jew I want you to wear a wig at all
times your hair is too sexy it's too
provocative
[Music]
cover your arms
and her Instagram is set to private
which I'm sure he loves oh yeah it's
perfect
lyrics
[Music]
yeah I'm glad to know we can have a
civil disagreements with chat
I was like do you think I think that she
violated his trust like too much either
he abuses his wife
but anyway I'm leaning more I'm leaning
towards uh I agree actually with her
doing that and the totality of
everything
of the accusation and also the group of
friends he cruises with
who's that Alexa who's that the girl who
was at the party when she was 16. that'd
be really interesting yeah literally
reach out to her I'd love to talk to her
uh but thank you guys
there it is Jonah Hill
so is he like um
this is gonna hurt his career maybe I
think I don't know
he's got 70 million dollars he's good
yeah he's good he'll be fine he'll be
fine
but at least he's covering her therapy
through the end of the year yeah
degenerous
we should crowdfund uh her therapy to
the end of this year
Sarah if you need more therapy money we
got you girl
and you don't even have dirt on me like
this I'll pay for your therapy let's go
come on Sarah
it's a show of good faith
if I could just update chat Lena is
alive oh my God Lena can I talk to you
Alina can I talk to you
of course
I heard you yacking
what happened I was
um so I was throwing up but the worst
part about that it was coming out of my
nose too dude it was so spicy like
holy [__] can you say spicy if it's in
your nose because you can't taste it but
I know what you mean it's just burn
noise it's still you got pepper sprayed
essentially yeah it was really really
hot and I just I didn't know what to do
and so as you were puking were you
regretting the decision to eat the
second one no you never regretted it
well
I do want to say just for love
if you're still here I'm here hey love
hi uh where are you guys sitting I'm
confused I'm over here just behind your
screen
oh okay I see you yeah
um love I want to say that you you win
this
you can have it because I I don't
oh how about uh
a split first place I don't I did not
want to win anything no you no no no I
don't want to steal your thunder I think
I just got a little something like Lena
got a hit of reality and he puked out of
her nose spicy no I don't care about it
and all I can think about was no I just
I
stole your thunder no no no I just I'm
not usually here for the segment so I
wanted to hold on to that title but
you got the title come on I never came
for it it's all yours and did it hurt
coming up when you react yeah because it
was it was spicy it was like
and was it blue was your puke blue yeah
chip that part was like red
that's no good red
yeah so I so you know we have like
Little Dixie cups in the bathroom I I
threw up a little bit in that one
because I wanted to examine it further
just to make sure it wasn't blood but it
wasn't okay good I was like I don't
remember seeing any red in there that's
the blood of God blood blood of God
hopefully not
I think you get you have the title you
know now is not the time to be humble
you did it you puked you [__] through
your nose you ate two yeah [__]
insane
I thought you were gonna die I literally
I thought someone was gonna die I hear
you I am curious to see how love handles
that because he was just so unfazed yeah
but that's up to you you know I blame
Dan to be honest me and I think it's
Dan's fault here why I do You Know Rich
lots of fright man
he's right about you I think he stole
the Thunder first it's all Dan's fault I
think love and Lena are the winners
sorry Dan wow
quite a betrayal you guys gonna fight
about it I'm reeling right now healing
right now Danny three chips right now
parking lot 5 p.m no thanks
no thanks I'm just kidding
I feel like the winner right now because
I'm the one eating ice cream
ice cream cam came out big time
[Applause]
tomorrow we will do it can I tell a real
quick kind of off topic but you were
just talking to cam and he's got a bird
on his head so it's kind of related and
my shoulders and your shoulders I've had
a jacket in my car since January and I
couldn't figure out who the [__] it is I
I didn't think to ask it was one you
guys so I'm cleaning out my car and I'm
like okay you know let's Jack in and I
feel something and there's a [__]
bird in there oh I I I died of of fear
oh you're you're right like a fake yeah
it was a fake bird who did that too it
was Cam's [__] jacket
[Music]
he travels with Woodland creatures
that's why write my name on my on my tag
when I can just put a bird in there yeah
I'm like this [__] well thank you for
returning the jacket it's my first
favorite jacket of course there it is
so um we have about 30 minutes left so
let's see Logan Paul still hasn't paid
people back for his giant scam which is
awesome what do you mean we have 30
minutes left
we have 30 minutes left no
of what so the show so I'm gonna end the
show
this just seems kind of Arbor like well
I'm gonna I want to leave at 4 30. oh
you have a time limit I want to leave at
4 30 so I can be home okay
yeah let me tell you about banana so
let's pick what we want we want to do
that I mean there's not much to it he
just hasn't paid anyone back he did this
massive scam coffee Zilla covered
and he was uh following it up
to see if he paid back he pledged 1.9
million dollars to pay back the zoo
what was it
crypto Zoo crypto Zoo yep and he has not
spent a dime and people don't care they
just don't care I don't know I think he
is taking some heat for it I mean the
coffee Zilla videos went real big right
but it's not affecting him at all like
his podcast is doing great he's in the
WWE he's selling Prime like nobody cares
he's engaged now
you hear about that
yeah I did actually yeah
so Mazel Tov no comment
strange when he's talking about prime
making 45 million in one month and then
still hasn't paid everybody back and
it's not even his first scam like he did
the
dude man this guy is like a criminal
he's like a Serial scammer yeah yeah I
mean definitionally like literally yeah
look at my face take a dump on my face
[Music]
this is the bane of Mike's existence
it's got the heat
um
so there's really not much to say about
it but uh pay up Logan coffee tweeted
you pay those people right part of his
Persona is like bet uh bragging about
how rich she is like okay
Logan Paul really is the type of Dude to
thank you when exposing his scam and
then block you when you remind him to
pay that is pretty great thank you
coffeezilla oh God I forgot
strawberry
I think his yeah
his first apology was a Hall of Famer I
wish he left it up
only recently surpassed in the apology
video Pauline took it to a new Champion
yeah she's like All Aboard Pauline is
like you know when baseball players
started taking steroids and they were
just like Mark McGuire yeah first the
break he's the Mark Maguire like Pauline
is the Mark McGuire of public the
previous record you know what I mean
close so Logan's like Barry Bonds yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no he's pre he's
pre-colline I'm saying oh right he was
the goat prior he was the goat until
Halloween took steroids yeah and just
crushed his record
yeah Mark Maguire that's so funny how he
got the record he's like a nobody and
then one year he's just like I broke the
record magically I think him and Barry
Bonds both of asterisks next to their
names
oh bear I didn't know Barry got busted
yeah yeah yeah
and Sammy Sosa go Ram is why don't we
just let everyone take steroids genuine
I kind of agree [__] it dude like we
want the game to be entertaining and
they're already taking it in that was
like the most exciting time yeah dude
they're like super human freaks that
they were hitting the ball like out into
the parking lot and [__] breaking
Windows
the stature of Maguire too like was he
massive like hey
I just don't get it you know let's just
get them on steroids enjoy the show yeah
have fun with it oh people want the calf
calf tea are you guys for real
you guys really want the Kev Kev tee
yeah that's exciting to me
that's exciting to me that you guys want
to hear me talk about cavcat that's so
awesome I can't tell you how meaningful
that is
I I read through it I got to say this
isn't the strongest Crab Cafe
I know you're excited about it but
seemed kind of
well let's see let's look at it
um this was a lawsuit filed
by the way if you guys don't know who
Kavanaugh is because we have
a lot of people watching just Google
Ryan Kavanaugh
Google's name
and when you get to this is him
when you get to the result page not sure
if that is him that's Harvey Weinstein
yeah it's actually a picture of Harvey
Weinstein it seems to be bugged out okay
well I have a website that can help with
confusion
so if you scroll down to does Ryan uh
Kavanaugh look like Harvey scene you
want to click that thing
and on this page we are doing a public
service to help
uh citizens oh tell the two apart right
and we have some really compelling stuff
I mean they look really similar but they
are different people at the end of the
day
look at that
wow this one is really I mean come on
wow too much wine sorry
yeah
so go ahead and spend some time on the
website right love right click around
around
look around we have a game if you guys
want to test your skill game on the
bottom
here he is donating a million dollars
Habitat Humanity which he didn't
actually give them interestingly 1.3
million dollars
but yeah check that out so let's see
last Wednesday no not this
okay so there's a new lawsuit
oh there's actually some kevkev memes
being silly with his young friends
just cave hanging out with Bryce Hall
bro
listen I got nothing wrong with Bryce I
like him I I mean I we did a show with
him he was great
but like Cav cab you need all you need
probably to hang out with people your
age thanks for taking care of her bro
is that 30 Cent legendary yes there is
okay that's fire these guys are having a
good time well they're both starring in
that movie together yeah remember this
this movie is going to be like one of
the worst movies has it straight up zero
percent Rotten Tomato Vibes what's it
called again that's my favorite kill
house skill house I cannot wait for this
cav-cav exclusive with 50 Cent I feel
like I've been hearing about it for so
long like is is it just keep getting
delayed
maybe they're putting their all into it
yeah the big project yeah huge is it
really not out yet there's it there's a
trailer we're in August of last year
there's a trailers yeah
it's just like a slasher movie these
they pump these things out Dan they kept
pushing back Avatar 2 and that was a
good quality so you know what it's gonna
be the next Avatar through Ryan
Cavanaugh is the new James Cameron you
got a good point
but I I didn't do this did not have a
release date online that you can find
because I'm excited about this
legitimately
angry sometime in 2023. oh wait now on
their Twitter analysis uh oh release
February 2024. wow this movie will have
been in production
Ryan you are such a loser
you ran the biggest Production Studio
it's gonna be good they were putting
time this thing look at what an idiot
you are literally you were the founder
of relative yeah that one right
relativity you may you were making the
biggest movies in the world bankrupted
that and now that you're trying to do a
50 cents ex Bryce Hall it's taking you
five years to make it firsthand just
give up man yeah
um
give up
here's uh here's kavkap backing up Bryce
hold me back hold me back bro
hold me back
oh this is Happy punch promo too no yeah
crossover that's Kim's company
[Music]
that was so uncomfortable what do you
think of those pants everything about
that made me everything about it is just
not working for me
go back to the moment that cab cap grabs
him yeah yeah yeah what does he like
really
you think hey don't do it bro it looks
like Bryce is grabbing him like he's
safe
help me Bryce
scared maybe kevkev was scared of
violent the violence breaking out and
he's siding behind Bryce
angry
do you think Bryce has [__] his wife
or no
Bryce said no he said no yeah you asked
him I asked him if he [__] his wife
I'm glad I asked that
thanks did we forget how epic that was
grab the bowl it was really funny and he
was he was nice
dude yeah Bryce is the man I like Bryce
um thanks for taking care of her bro so
there's a new lawsuit yeah exactly
let's see
okay so I'm gonna do all the disclaimers
I have to do here let's do like all the
alleged leads and stuff
in fact in fact can you put allegedly on
the screen we have one of those right so
you can't even pull a frame
why don't we just use the we disavow
everything this dumbass is saying oh
okay anything's opinion that's good we
disavowed everything it's just in
reference to you this that's good I mean
that works that's funny if they try to
screenshot that
I don't know if it will work though
maybe in Ethan's opinions yeah
anything's opinion everything in this
article yeah Ian's suggesting both
share both
this stuff is sourced uh from a
statement that he put out okay if we
just read uh what's in the dock there's
nothing let me read his statement yeah
so um this is super interesting I nobody
knew about this until dumbass put out a
statement about it
yeah he's really good at whatever
dumbass
hold on so here's his statement I'm just
going to read it
this is good
oh yeah you guys are gonna love this
in the past days an Insidious extortion
plot devised by a former girlfriend
whom I dated over two years ago and have
no contact with in two years Jane Doe
that's the classic hey it was two years
ago I I clearly didn't do it
now I'm not saying he is an abuser I'm
just saying that's a line I see all the
time where it's like hey I didn't talk
to her for two years
[Music]
you know what I mean foreign
that can't be her real name I'm kidding
no yeah obviously not
and her legal representative Kurt
schneck
have been directed against me Nick hey
it began as an attempt to tarnish my
professional reputation which of course
has been sterling silver up until now
yeah not a single blemish
and my business interests through
untruthful allegations when they're fine
when their financial demands were not
met they escalated their tactics making
false allegations involving my eldest
son which they threatened to leak to the
Press unless they received 550.
[Music]
okay
misto has already managed to extract a
hundred thousand from triller wait how
did she get money from triller that's
what I look I love this statement like
you said it's like nobody was paying
attention nobody cared
now like you're not interesting enough
to anybody be interested in in your
blackmail extortion plot or whatever but
now you wrote this
and now I'm very curious about all of it
yeah because and then also what's super
interesting is as I understand it when
this lawsuit was filed it was the same
thing with the Variety article where it
got it was filed and then it got pulled
really fast before it reached the
clerk's office
super weird so it wasn't even officially
filed but he's like yeah it's not so
weird is that it's the same thing that
happened to variety
hmm
but then he's like no I gotta talk about
this all this [__] that nobody heard
about
so let's see she extracted a hundred
thousand from triller I don't know what
that means
her claim I've extracted money from
trailer I guess well sixty thousand yeah
I I believe in my opinion not evens and
I could be wrong but based on reading
the article I think what it was saying
was that she had uh they did some sort
of settlement or something with her
because she wanted to work at triller
and she claimed that Ryan Kavanaugh
would not allow her to get that job and
they made a decision without Ryan
Kavanaugh to give her money oh so what a
dumbass then like that's super
misleading the way he wrote it
she she got paid rightfully from triller
right unrelated I mean you could call
that extracting I guess anything's
extracted
you guys extract a lot of money yeah
extract the salary from you stop
extracting from it
her claim was that after we broke up she
wanted to be employed by triller however
I and triller kept her from being
employed by triller due to our prior
relationship dude I totally believe you
wouldn't do that I 100 believe that you
Ryan Kavanaugh would not go out of your
way to block your ex from working at the
company that you partially you would
never no I totally believe him I'm glad
he put this statement out yeah
I'm so glad he said that because I
totally believe it
this allegation was false I agree and I
strongly disagree with triller's
decision to pay for threats of
dissemination and false information
however trailer considering the high
potential legal cost and the
inconvenience of a lengthy legal process
decided to opt for a convenience payment
I had no involvement in distraction
transaction nor did I support it
and I refused to sign any release or
documents at the time
now after more than two years it appears
Mrs doe and her now third attorney Mr
schneck have come back to the well
they intentionally timed their latest
um they intentionally timed their latest
demand to coincide with a significant
event for triller Aquino speech at a
major Wall Street conference
nobody nobody cares
nobody was watching that
and amid their filing to go public
nobody cares how are you how do you go
public given over you have nothing
they have no bag I'm gonna take our
whatever Kevin Hart
oh wait no they had to remove that oh no
they don't know that's right they had I
we should make our website public we're
gonna make an IPO the Ryan Kavanaugh
does Ryan come out look like Harvey
Weinstein
let's see this timing was clearly
designed to inflict maximum reputational
damage on both trailer and myself these
allegations albeit baseless
could still cause significant short-term
damage until proven false in court a
process that could take years as we have
seen in other recent high profile cases
talk about
it's so crazy I mean so many people are
trying to ruin his reputation he said
the same thing about me
[Music]
Twitter it's like a pattern it's weird
stop
stop I believe him a hundred percent
but it is strange the pattern
it gets worse so trust me stick with me
stick with it all right we're sticking
around
when they're escalating demands for an
immediate payment of 550 000 did not
influence me their tactics changed Mr
schnick Behavior grew increasingly
erratic and alarming shifting from text
threats to email threads oh no Mr he he
upped his game instead of texting me he
started emailing me whoa
that's super important to email
his message suggested that if the
payment wasn't made within hours they
would release statements to the press
that would ruin me
tell me about those Ryan
new allegations which had never been
raised during our entire relationship
after our breakup or for the past few
years post breakup have never been so
much as mentioned or concerns allegation
otherwise again not the best defense she
never told me that she was upset about
it
so he says what began began with
insinuations of sexual harassment say
more
hold on she accused you of what or she
insinuated that you did what sexually
harassed
I think that the uh the complaint is
public
I think we can access it and read from
the complaint
[Music]
which we should do I don't know if you
can pull that up get the other side of
the story huh I maybe I've tried looking
for it
well I might have it in my email oh do
you yeah I might have it
somebody emailed it to you maybe that
seems like an escalation
right
yeah
straight to my inbox man what a what a
what a violation of my privacy
um
one sec here all right while you look
for that take a look at some of these
supers
from all of our super duper uh fans am I
right
uh uh oh God they're all just about like
Jonah Hill from 30 minutes ago
um are they telling me there's one that
says W Dan with a cute little star doing
on a loot your star
w-nie Wan
cheers my dudes cheers my dude
um
here's another generic one somebody just
said love
foreign
yeah
yeah we don't have the dumbass alert up
for these these are our paying fans oh
yeah we don't disavow this
[Music]
um
do you think Jonah's surfer girl knows
cav-cav's Surfer guy Alt
such a good question
so glad y'all are back great job Luna
and Zach's sound bite game [__]
thank you dh2
thank you my dude thank you my dude
um let's see my beautiful wife
Holly is pregnant again after losing our
first baby last year I'm sorry to hear
that she turns 30 tomorrow
it would mean so much if you all could
wish her a happy birthday thank you 30.
happy birthday happy happy birthday good
luck yes and congratulations
uh what else we got here
Ethan's little Pillsbury Doughboy laugh
is what keeps me going in life and
brings me joy
thank you
uh we need an apology video bracket
Showdown uh yeah yeah not a bad idea
have we not done that I feel like we did
I feel like maybe we did but it would
probably be long enough ago that I would
certainly I love some recent entries
have been strong yeah let's put it
together for sure yep
um you can even put my apology to um
cutie Cinderella which uh that oh yeah
we could include psychology and Seattle
gave let's remind everybody a perfect
10. a perfect 10 out of 10. wow perfect
10 out of 10 apology yeah
Derek runs just threw in 10 bucks and
said shout out to the goats Lena and
love see there's no need for
no need for anything between you two
you're both the goat thank you both the
goat very impressive love uh thank you
Derek I do want to say though Lena got
some [__] because they're saying that
some people were saying that she was
making up rules as she goes uh that may
be true no no it's kind of hard to to
think in that moment whenever you're
dying from that pain if I'm it's not
true she was in New Territory she's she
defines what the rules are
okay yeah she was trailblazing anybody
complaining about the fact that Lena ate
two chips is [__] insane in the first
place she puked out of her nose is that
not enough are you guys insane you're
not entertained but yeah I thought if if
those are the rules I would have stuck
to it but like Ethan's saying I thought
it's a different game I think it'll
different back babe yeah you did
something very different you did
something very different
oh here's an interesting one
uh
uh Elizabeth said Ethan I'm still trying
to figure out how to get tunecore to
drop the violetta's copyright claim
again see you next Tuesday where we
listen to the music
what remember that here it's still how
why is it what the f is she's still
working on it well she donated 20 to let
you know that so I'm sorry I don't know
I I wish there was an easier way to do
it that's crazy
talk to Colleen's lawyer apparently
although she her claim is still up so I
don't know wait I'm seeing she actually
donated like three or four times with
the same message I guess because we she
was fearing we wouldn't see I I've used
tunecore well thank you tune core before
there is a thing on their back end where
you can whitelist a channel and it
should release it yeah well maybe reach
out to Zach and he can help you figure
that out yeah
did you find it no I'll move on I'll get
it for later all right you go ahead
so what began with insinuations of
sexual harassment
then move to false allegations of drug
use oh my goodness
and finally stoop to the lowest point
imaginable suggesting they would make
false claims involving child
endangerment
something they knew would hit me hardest
as it involved my children the most
important part of my life so let's recap
his ex-girlfriend
is claiming or insinuating his words
that he sexually harassed her I think
I assume so she's claiming that um
he's using drugs which is Vibes Ryan I'm
not gonna hate on that unless you're I
mean you probably coked out all the time
right
Maybe
probably I mean we're speculating here
we have no way of knowing just remember
this any sort of drugs hey dumbass just
remember this yeah there's no factual
insinuation here it's just pure
speculation a Hollywood producer there
is this is a cooking town
the real question is was Ryan at Jason
Long's party we don't know
show me again hey uh hi Ryan's lawyers
I'm glad you're getting paid like 800 an
hour just to watch this
that's a good grief that you guys have
going with Ryan but not bad oh yeah yeah
no you are sucking him dry well it's
[__] insane because he's spending so
much on attorneys and then he's like
I need you to pay for my attorneys
like what it's not my fault you went and
got the 800 an hour idiots
like he for our um for our settlement or
our mediation meeting he brought out two
lawyers from this insanely expensive
firm they flew out from New York
can you imagine how much money he must
have spent for that oh much oh that's
insane
it's like bro he's an idiot hey dummy
a dummy
you're [__] ugly dude I don't know my
opinion thank you so according to your
your ex-girlfriend you sexually harassed
her made somebody somebody yeah use
drugs which I you know and then says
actually you endangered your children
that is [__] up I agree with you
he says it's so low it's on it's
unimaginably low that you endangered
your children
somebody said that about you damn
now I believe you of course but it's
crazy somebody said that about you even
[Music]
what was it that I said
that somebody said in a filing that you
endangered your children
that's [__] up that she said that
which is not true probably because I
believe you
the situation involved from a typical
breakup where one party Jane Doe didn't
accept the end of our relationship at
the time more than two years ago of
course a scorned lover who could resist
the hunky
Charming
just as long as he doesn't drink and
drive
into an unjust assault of my character
and my wallet and finally more than two
years later into a clear extortionist
plot that threatened to harm my
relationship with my children
oh no
I assure you I stand firm fight these
allegations and protect what's most
dearest to me
during my career I have weathered
adversaries and navigated through
unfounded criticism
the brave Explorer he is
however I draw the line firmly when it
comes to my children the very thought
that someone would manipulate
information concerning a child's welfare
for a financial gain is deeply
disturbing or alarming is the fact that
such egregious falsehoods could create
created for
hunk
puny oh puniary motives
he dance in the bathroom I can't read
either
let's look it up
here let's see what pecuniary acute
pecuniary
relating to or consisting of money like
punitive
pecuniary pecuniary let's ask Dan if he
knows what it is 800 DPI Dan
do you know what PQ nieri means
do you know what pecuniary means
what's the word hold on close your eyes
because I don't want you to see the I'll
play the pronunciation of it pecuniary
pecuniary yeah epi pecuniary can I can
you read in the sentence
says more alarming is the fact that such
egregious falsehoods could be created
for pecuniary motives
uh pecuniary I mean
it seems like the same root as peculiar
perhaps and so some sort of strange
untoward motives
is that right no it has to no that's not
right okay relating to a consisting of
money DPI that's a new one for me that's
the word of the day everybody
so um
it's incredible he put the statement out
oh yeah so he says during my career I've
weathered adversaries and navigated
through unfounded criticism
uh yeah yeah Jane Doe is the same
individual who once claimed that
watching me with my children made her
heart explode with love
she said that but then she changed her
mind she was a part of my life shared
countless hours when they spent time
with my children and met my family and
friends oh so she knows you really well
this same person after all these
experiences now seeking to inflict harm
on my loved ones by exploiting our past
relationship it sounds to me from
reading this that she knows you really
well
and if anybody were to lay these claims
against him
and have a credible accusation it would
be her
that being said I believe Ryan Kavanaugh
and she's lying she's she's probably
lying yeah for sure but if
why does it lie like if somebody's gonna
say oh you abuse children
oh you sexually harass people
um what else did she say oh you
drug use like if if there was somebody
in his life
with the in the position to know those
things it would be her
yeah
I think that's fair
she's a lot she's lying though I believe
Ryan
let me be clear my children are my world
insecure that's giving me like uh
that's giving me um
what was it where you said my children
are not responsible for this what was
that we were just watching
well that was prouder that was prouder
it's not my kids the one thing that my
Northern stars that my kids aren't
responsible for us getting divorced it's
like no yeah no
let me be clear my children are my world
I will spare no effort to Shield them
from the morally deplorable conduct of
Jane Doe and her lawyer Kirk schneck
he's coming for Kirk Captain Kirk
their innocence and safety are my utmost
priority
yeah nobody's saying anything about them
dude and I will not allow these
falsehoods to compromise that
I have nothing to hide in the interest
of full transparency I'm willing to make
all written Communications between
myself and Jane Doe my ex-girlfriend as
well as her lawyer extortionist
Communications available to any member
of the press interested in reporting the
true nature of our relationship starting
and can we get a hold of that
do we know anyone from the Press
I'm depressed technically in a way
you're depressed
I'm depressed
[Music]
both are true
um it's 4 30 just so you know wait can I
what if I wrote from my personal I was
like hey yo it's Ethan Klein from the
Press can you provide me all that [__]
even climbed from the Press
born on the streets of the press we
stand firm in our commitment to truth
and Justice who's we
and we trust that these principles will
guide us through these challenging times
no you're being accused of this [__] I
don't know who's wheat
your continued support and understand I
greatly appreciate it as we navigate
this situation I love how he goes your
continues for it who
I think I'm the only person that's read
this
what
we stand firm in our commitment to truth
and Justice oh yeah I read that so just
to just to um
just to summarize
his ex-girlfriend
accused him of sexual harassment
drug use and child endangerment
a girlfriend he was with for a
substantial amount of time it sounds
like by the way he described it
and so of course she would be in that
position to know all those things about
him and that's what makes it so
Insidious of a lie it's because she
would know
if anyone in his life would know it
would be her and that's why it's such a
dangerous Insidious lie
foreign
do people have to not trust her
right
that's why it's such a dangerous life
true you look at her and you look at
Ryan and Ryan's reputation is just
horrible I mean you go to our you go to
our website and you look at all the [__]
he's done he's not very credible he's
lied
um just as a matter of doing business
right
and so if you put him up against this
woman who's very credible by I haven't
seen any reason we're not could not
believe her
I haven't seen any reason not to believe
her
then according his statement anyways
right not in this right not in this
statement so of course I would I would
my natural inclination would say oh
she's telling the truth
my natural inclination would be to say
Ryan Kavanaugh and dangerous children
right and sexually harassed that's
what's so [__] up but that's why it's
such an Insidious lie I know for sure
because she's so believable and he's so
unbelievable yeah no that's real [__]
up actually that's what's so Insidious
about this and it's it's [__] up that
she's extorting him
kind yeah I mean come on so that's
that's kind of oh we can listen to audio
of it
where's the audio
Ryan yeah Kavanaugh files lawsuit
against LA attorney Kirk shank and
client Jane Doe over extortion scheme
let me go to the middle of time
now third attorney Mr shank have come
back to the well
they intentionally timed their latest
demand to coincide with a significant
event for triller a keynote speech at a
major Wall Street conference and amid
their filing to go I want to know if the
AI voice could hit that it's clearly
designed to inflict cuniary properly oh
it's coming up I'm a reputational damage
on both triller and myself these
alligators in court a process that could
take high profile cases Mr shank's
Behavior grew increasingly erratic and
alarm ligations or otherwise
whatever so that's
that's the problem with this new one and
I'm firmly on his side
and uh also Stan BTS
[Music]
Stan BTS Bandcamp
uh shout out to LG for the 10 gifty
subbies here members or whatever you
want to call it
LG yeah but even though I believe him
he's such a piece of [__] man I [__]
hate that guy there's also a super chat
from my girlfriend Ally saying Dan can
you pick up some Nair on the way home
are you serious ly
oh is that a pass I love that yeah I was
from a few minutes ago let's narrow that
butthole and film it put on YouTube
yes Dan yeah stop holding out on us
laughs
all right you have to leave yeah you
were the one who put a limit on people
want us to talk about Boogie's new
girlfriend which is pretty fun we can
talk about that on Friday yeah we'll get
uh on Friday I guess
he's dating a 20 year old and he's like
50. he's not like 50. he's like 48 I
think is he 50. he's almost two age 20.
he's 48 yeah and he goes we met when she
was 19. like he's trying to make it
sound as dumb as he even can he goes we
met when she was 19. she's a fan and
then we started again and then we
started getting intimate when she was
20. this is what happens when you hang
out with keemstar uh right away
true learning from you dad there's going
to be a lot of tweets about this between
now and Friday
what about us talking about every time
we Edge these guys a little bit oh
Boogie yeah he's he's funny now he
always takes he's like
well we talked about how he like became
anti-h3 all of a sudden for no reason
yeah
but I mean listen I I understand the
hustle you're in get those views boy
yeah he is actually dumb bad like he's
doing unbelievable so I I like go for it
I think the H3 videos probably do fairly
well oh yeah I think so so I'd yeah I
mean he needs it and I mean listen
dating a 20 year old girl you got to
keep her you got to keep the action
going you need a little money to make it
worth her time yeah nice dinners
bags come on let's get those H3 videos
out
only five years older than Ethan okay
first of all [__] you I'm 38.
40 years he's why did you even get the
four he's ten years older than me 48
minus 43 is five yeah
he's 10 years older than the math checks
out
Boogie so awesome
all right
um so that's it you know uh
just keep Cav Cab in your minds keep him
close to your heart he's going through
really hard times
and he's just awful he's being accused
of these horrible things sexual
harassment drug use and child
endangerment
and even though she's super credible and
I have no reason not to believe her
that's what's [__] up and I think that
she this is so out of control that she
filed this and I'm firmly in Ryan's spot
here he's big of you I believe it set
aside your differences I believe him
yeah
I believe Brian
he's the [__] man dude I love Ryan
Cavanaugh
all right well that's the show thank you
guys for all being here appreciate y'all
I hope you guys
I'm Legit like I think people are gonna
stop watching because I said I wondered
if
um
if uh Jonah Hill's ex-girlfriend
overshared
[Music]
what can you do though what will be will
be you know too bad
I hope you don't
I ended up agreeing with you
you know
I won't worry about it too much I end up
agreeing oh people are asking if
leftovers are happening tomorrow yes yes
we back hell yeah we'll be back
so
10 a.m Pacific
and by that I mean probably like 10 15
Pacific yeah usually about 15 minutes
late
no he's here he's back in La so yep
and we have a lot of good stuff to talk
about we got a lot of stuff to talk
about and uh yeah because we actually
didn't have an episode of leftovers the
week of the live show either
because he was out of town so it's
actually been three weeks wow The Boys
Are Back In Town yeah sure
Boys Are Back In Town all right guys
thank you to our wonderful audience we
love you so much thank you to everyone
who's being here thanks to our members
who make it all possible and we will be
back on Thursday with leftovers at 10
A.M and Friday at 1 p.m for after dark
great shows ahead thank you all for
being here it's the H3 podcast
we're not going anywhere
[Music]